DATES ITEMS NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
THREE SEVENTY NINE BY SUMMER MAN
SHINE I AM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE ONE FIVE BY SUMMER MATH
THIS ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTEEN BY SOMEONE SYRIAN.
I'M NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY NINE BY CIMBER WOODS WITH
THE MEN'S SO THE I AM NUMBER
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TEN FORTY TWO BY
SUMMER WOULD -- I NUMBER FIFTEEN
EIGHTY TENTH AT EIGHTY FIVE BY
SUMMER MCCARTY AND I AND NUMBER
SIXTEEN EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
BY SUMMER WOULD.
SO THOSE ITEMS ARE ON OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT -- CENTER GROVE --
WHEEL OF FORTUNE NOT BE ABLE TO
TEN TODAY SHE IS -- SHE
REPRESENTS THEORY BEING AFFECTED
BY THE EARTHQUAKES AND SO SHE IS
IN HER DISTRICT -- TAKING CARE
OF HER CONSTITUENTS AT TOWN HALL --
THIS AGAIN REMINDER OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES -- WE ALLOW UP
TO SIX MINUTES OF TESTIMONY ON
EACH SIDE.
IF YOU HAVE MULTIPLE TESTS THE
FIRES THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DIVIDE UP THE SIX MINUTES --
AND THEN WE'LL DO AFTER THE
TESTIMONY WE TAKE -- ESSENTIALLY.
ADDITIONAL TESTS MAY THE BACK
MICROPHONE WHICH WOULD DROP THAT
INCLUDE THE NAME OF THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE PERSON
REPRESENTS A REALIZATION AND
POSITION SO NO FURTHER.
TESTIMONY THAN THAT SO AT THAT
TIME A WELCOME EVERYONE HERE --
SAID NOTING THE LACK OF A QUORUM
WE'RE GONNA GO HEAD BEGAN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND I'LL START WITH
ITEM NUMBER ONE FOLLOW ORDER --
IT'S SP SIX SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR UMBERG WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE MEMBERS
BEING PRESENT HERE SHORTLY --
BEFORE USE S. B. SIX SIX FIVE IT
WOULD MAKE A SMALL CHANGE THE
LAW WHICH COULD RESULT IN MAJOR.
POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR MANY
INDIVIDUAL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES UNDER PROP SIXTY
THREE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDS ARE NOT.
PERMITTED TO BE SPENT IN STATE
PRISONS THIS ISSUE IS RESOLVED
THE SITUATION WHERE CERTAIN
POPULATIONS THAT COULD USE THESE
FUNDS THE MOST AND OF BEING
RESTRICTED FROM RECEIVING.
PROGRAMS AND TREATMENTS THAT
THEY REALLY NEED ORANGE COUNTY
FOR EXAMPLE -- IT HAS
APPROXIMATELY 30% OF ITS
INCARCERATED POPULATION WITH A
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE.
AND IN FACT THE COUNTY JAILS.
PROBABLY THE PLACE WHERE YOU SEE
MORE INDIVIDUALS NEEDING MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT THAN ANY OTHER
GROUP -- OR GROUP BEING WITHIN
THE STATE.
ACCORDING TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN DATA FROM THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
APPROXIMATELY ONE FIFTH OF
COUNTY JAIL INMATES.THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE TAKING
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS A 25%
INCREASE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN SEVERAL IN ORANGE
COUNTY -- OUR NEW SHERIFF SURE
OF DON BARNES IS MOVED -- TO TO
STOP HOLDING I. C. E. --
DETAINEES IT IS NOW WORKING TO
FREE UP ACTUALLY THAT SPACE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CASES -- WITH THE
NUMBER OF INCARCERATED WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND LIMITED FUNDING
SOURCES FOR TREATMENT IT'S
CRITICAL TO EXPLORE THE
FLEXIBILITY OF EXISTING MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDING SOURCES.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WOULD
DO IT WOULD PERMIT THE MONIES --
A CERTAIN M. H. S. A. FUNDS TO
BE USED PROVIDE MENTAL SERVICES.
TO THOSE WHO ARE IN CARS OR IN
COUNTY JAILS NOT FOR PHONES NOT
FOR STATE PRISONS IT IS FOR
COUNTY JAILS.
IT IS A OF AN INVESTMENT IT'S AN
INVESTMENT IN IN MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
IN OUR COUNTY JAILS THE GOING TO
BE RELEASED.
AND IF THEY HAVE.
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT THE ODDS
OF THEM RECEIVING.
DECREASED DRAMATICALLY AND SO AS
A CONSEQUENCE WE'VE WE'VE
INTRODUCED SB SIX SIX FIVE A
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS
MISTER RICHARD SANCHEZ THE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH SERVICES FOR
ORANGE COUNTY -- AMY JENKINS
REPRESENTING ORANGE COUNTY AND
FOR PURPOSES OF ANSWERING
QUESTIONS JEFF NAGEL THE
DIRECTOR OF ORANGE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL.
HEALTH SERVICES THANK THANK YOU
WITNESS IS A SPORT THE SPIN.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RICHARD
SANCHES AS THE SENATOR SAID I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY HEALTH CARE AGENCY AND I
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF PROVIDING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR BOTH
THE INCARCERATED IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND ALSO THE MEDICARE
POPULATION IN ORANGE COUNTY.
AND I SEE A STARK DIFFERENCE IN
THE SERVICES THAT I CAN SUPPLY
TO THOSE POPULATIONS.
CURRENT LAWS THE SENATOR SAID --
IS SILENT ON THE USE OF M. HSA
DOLLARS.
FOR PEOPLE INCARCERATED IN
COUNTY JAILS AT THE SAME TIME
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS AS THE
CENTER SAID WE SEE AN INCREASE
OF 30%.
IN OUR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
RELATED TO OUR JAIL POPULATION
THAT'S JUST OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS SO IT'S TREMENDOUS GROWTH
TREMENDOUS GROWTH.
AS HE SAID ALSO THAT THE JAIL
HAS BECOME THE DE FACTO LARGEST
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY IN THE
COUNTY.
AND AT THE SAME TIME WITH
LIMITED RESOURCES.
AS THE PROVIDER OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES I RECOGNIZE THE SIMPLE
REALITY THAT INCARCERATED
PERSONS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ARE THE SAME PERSON
SUFFERING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
UPON THE RELEASE.
I SEE THEM ON BOTH SIDES I SEE
THEM IN THEIR CARS RATED I SEE
THEM WHEN THEY'RE HOMELESS ON
THE STREET.
THIS IS THE SAME POPULATION ONE
SIDE GETS A LOT OF SERVICE ONE
SIDE MAYBE NOT SO MUCH.
THIS BILL PROVIDES S. PROVIDES
IN THIS NECESSARY CLARITY TO ME
JUST SAY AND WOULD AUTHORIZE
THOSE DOLLARS TO BE INCLUDED IF
THEY'RE PART OF THE IMAGE SAY
ANNUAL PLAN. TO FUND TREATMENT
FOR PERSONS INCARCERATED IN THE
COUNTY JAIL ARE SUBJECT TO
MANDATORY SUPERVISION IS EXCEPT
FOR THOSE.
INCARCERATED FOR A CONVICTION OF
A FELONY.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT THIS BILL BILL
PROVIDES AN OPTION TO COUNTIES
TO PLAN FOR AND UTILIZE ANOTHER
FUNDING SOURCE TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT.
AND RE ENTRY SERVICES FOR THOSE
IN COUNTY JAIL. TO ENSURE THE
BEST POSSIBLE OUTCOME THAT IS
ESSENTIAL TO CREATE A SYSTEM
THAT SUPPORTS PEOPLE.
AS THE TRANSITION BOTH IN AND
OUT OF JAIL. FOR THOSE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU JOIN
ORANGE COUNTY SUPPORTING THIS
BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ARE PROUD
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL I'M GOING
TO BEGIN BY BY THINKING THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
FORWARD.
AS ALREADY STATED -- THE COUNTY
IT WANTS TO ENSURE THAT MENTALLY
ILL INDIVIDUALS INCARCERATED IN
COUNTY JAILS RECEIVE TREATMENT
AND ARE GIVEN THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY POSSIBLE TO RETURN
TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND BE
SUCCESSFUL.
ANY USE OF THESE FUNDS WOULD
STILL BE REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH
THE SAME PUBLIC PROCESS REQUIRED
OF ALL MHSAA PROGRAMMING FOR
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE TODAY AND
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
SCENE OF BACK MY PHONE --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT AND IF YOU COULD JUST MAKE
SOME ROOM FOR THEM EITHER
SHUFFLED THE CIDER [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
HAVE ALREADY WITH ACCOUNT IF YOU
HAVE A HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION REGRET FOR WE WE ARE
OPPOSED ON LAST SIGH I POSE TO
SB SIX SIX FIVE UNLESS AMENDED
TO NARROW THE BILL TO BE A PILOT
PROGRAM -- TIME LIMITED UNDER
THE INNOVATION COMPONENT OF THE
ACT -- TOO WITH AN EVALUATION
COMPONENT TO SEE IF THIS NEW
USAGE AT AN HSA FUNDS REDUCES
INCARCERATION IN PRISON LINKAGES
TO COMMUNITY TREATMENT.
AND PROVE HOUSING ATTAINMENT AND
EMPLOYMENT OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
WOULD RECEIVE SERVICES THROUGH
THIS NEW USE OF FUNDING.
THE IMAGES SAY AND CURRENT LAW
INCLUDES AN EXCLUSION OF USING
THE FUNDING FOR STATE
CORRECTIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
THEN ADDITIONALLY DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES HAS
INTERPRETED THIS ENTITLE NINE
REGULATIONS. TO MEAN THAT YOU
CAN ONLY USE AN HSA FUNDS FOR
FACILITATING DISCHARGE WITH TOM
FROM COUNTY FACILITIES.
THIS BILL WOULD END UP
CONSTITUTING USAGE I'VE MHSAA
FUNDS IN THE TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
SENTENCING PROJECT ENDED UP
DOING A RANKING OF ALL FIFTY
STATES A BASED ON THEIR ACCESS
TO MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT AND
THEN THEIR INCARCERATION RATES --
SIX OF THE TEN TOP STATES THAT
HAD THE LEAST ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH HAD THE FIVE AXIS THE
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH.
HAD THE HIGHEST INCARCERATION
RATES.
THE INTENT OF THE M. HSA AS
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS IS TO
REDUCE THE LONG TERM ADVERSE
OUTCOMES -- UNTREATED MENTAL
ILLNESS IN AND P. I. SECTION
THIS IS SPECIFIED EVEN CLEAR
THAT ONE OF THE GOALS AT THE
MHSAA IS TO REDUCE THE
INCARCERATION OF INDIVIDUALS --
OUR MEMBERS HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BLANKET
REMOVAL -- THE EXCLUSION OF
PROVIDING SERVICES IN JAILS --
AND THE POTENTIAL TO HAVE
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH DOLLARS
DIVERTED INTO AN INSTANT A
LOCKED INSTITUTION -- WHILE THIS
BILL IS PERMISSIVE AND SAYING
THAT FUNDING FOR THEM WOULD BE
FOR THIS PURPOSE AND THEIR THREE
YEAR PLAN SUBJECT TO THE
COMMUNITY PLANNING PROCESS.
NOT ALL OF THESE DECISIONS ARE
MADE AT THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR LEVEL AND MAY BE MADE
BY THE CEO OR SEE A THIS OFFICE
TO PUNT.
AND THEY MAY FIND PUBLIC SAFETY
OVER COMMUNITY IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH.
WE DO SUPPORT PROVIDING -- HIGH
QUALITY -- SERVICES IN JAILS TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED THEM BUT
NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF LIFESAVING
COMMUNITY TREATMENT WHICH CAN
HELP PREVENT INDIVIDUALS FROM
BEING INCARCERATED IN THE FIRST
PLACE -- IN ADDITION WE BELIEVE
THAT A PILOT PROGRAM WITH THIS
TIME LIMITED WITH EVALUATION.
IS NECESSARY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE IMPACT OF THESE JAIL BASED
SERVICES WOULD END UP BEING.
AND OUR PONDER REENTRY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO STAY IN THE
COMMUNITY AND WE REPRESENT ALL
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS APPROACH GEO BASED
CARE AND FUNDING IN A WAY TO
SUPPORT THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT A PILOT PROGRAM
FOR THIS PURPOSE WOULD ALLOW
ORANGE COUNTY AND OTHER
INTERESTED COUNTIES TO ALLOCATE
THIS PURPOSE THIS FUNDING TO
MEET THEIR LOCAL NEEDS.
WHILE ALSO ADDRESSING BROADER
CONCERNS OF FROM OTHER MEMBERS
WHO NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE DO
NOT PULL OUT.
THE THE RUG FROM THE LARGER SET
OF OUR IMAGE IS A FUN AND
SERVICES INCLUDING MHSAA WHICH
IS USED TO LEVERAGE ON MEDIC COW
MATCH.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSED WITH -- SENATOR UMBERG
IN ORANGE COUNTY -- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE CONTINUE TO BE
A POET MY CEMENTED ON THE BILL
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
A SINGING NUN TURNS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SO ACTUALLY -- MAYBE I CAN
HAVE SOME OF YOUR PROPONENT
WITNESSES COME BACK UP FROM HER
UNDER COUNTY HAS HAD ITS SHARE
YES I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS YES
IT'S LIKE THE WHAT WHAT OTHER
COMING UP MAY RESPOND -- YES
ACTUALLY -- YEAH WE DO WANT YOU
I WAS GOING TO SAY THAT I WAS
GONNA ASK THEM BUT WHAT I'LL GO
IN THE GUT LEVY OUT CENTER OF IT
PLEASE RESPOND TO THE OPPOSITE A
COUPLE THINGS ONE THAT WE ARE
UNAWARE THE OPPOSITION TILL MOST
RECENTLY AND WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
WORK.
WITH THE OPPONENTS NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO IS IS ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE THEM MAKING PROBABLY
THE STRONGEST -- PROVIDE
DESTROYS BIT OF EVIDENCE IS THE
NECESSITY FOR THIS BILL AND AND
THAT IS I I WASN'T AWARE THAT
THE STATES WITH AT LEAST ACCESS.
TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES HAVE
THE HIGHEST INCARCERATION RATES
WHICH WHICH PROVES MY POINT THE
POINT IS IS THAT THIS IS
PROBABLY THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
PLACE TO PROVIDE TREATMENT TERMS
OF RECIDIVISM.
BOTH FOR THE INDIVIDUAL AS WELL
AS FOR THE COMMUNITY -- AND YOU
YOU HAD SOME OTHER QUESTIONS
MISTER CHAIR -- YES SO SO
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE SO WHEN THE
CAT QUESTIONS I HAD WAS -- IN
RELATION TO SO FIRST OF ALL
UNDER THE ACT YOU CAN'T SUPPLANT.
SO IT'S SO WHAT KIND OF FOR
EXAMPLE.
WHAT KIND OF THINGS AS ORANGE
THAT'S IN WHICH YOU'RE SEEKING
THIS LEGISLATION SO I RECOGNIZE
CERTAINLY THE JAIL IS BUT I
THINK THE OPPOSITION DOES POINT
OUT.
THIS IS ABOUT KEEPING PEOPLE OUT
OF INCARCERATION WE WIDE DIED I
WANT TO GIVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE FUNDS SO THAT
WOULD HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED MOVE HALTS OKAY
JUST PERHAPS SPEAK -- TO THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION AND
HOW YOU ANTICIPATE -- WITH THIS
FLEXIBILITY USE IT -- USING YOUR
IMAGES SAFE FUNDS THAT YOU'RE
SPEAKING WITH THROUGH THIS BILL.
I'M THE NONSTOP PLANTATION -- A
RULE WITHIN THE MAIL SERVICES
ACT.
REQUIRES THAT -- A PROGRAMS THAT
EXISTED PRIOR TO THE PASSING OF
THE ACT CANNOT BE REPLACED WITH --
AN HSA FUNDING SO AN EXPANSION
OF SERVICES -- WOULD NOT BE
COVERED BY THAT -- NON SUPPLANT
ROLE.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT
SERVICES WOULD BE USED -- RATE
SO YES I AM CURIOUS AS TO WHAT
KIND OF THINGS YOU WOULD BE
DOING AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
STATEMENT ABOUT AN EXPANSION
LOOKING AT PIECE OF PLANTATION --
THAT ACTUALLY RAISES PEOPLE'S
ANXIETIES BECAUSE WHAT WE DON'T
WANT TO DO SEE AND IT'S IT'S A
FUN SIMPLY BEING USED.
TO BECAUSE IT'S A LARGER JAIL
POPULATION SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
WHAT KIND INNOVATIONS ARE THINGS
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT IN
RELATION -- TO USE OF AN HSA
FUNDS IN ORANGE COUNTY.
YEAH YES -- IT IN WITHIN OUR
JAILS WE HAVE THE SAME
POPULATION NEEDS IN OUR MENTAL.
ARE MENTALLY ILL THAT WE DO ON
THE STREETS SO WOULD B VERY
SIMILAR TO THE SERVICES THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING. TO OUR MANAGES
A FUNDED NOW ACCEPTED WOULD BE
WITH THE CAPTIVE POPULATION THAT
WE CAN TREAT AND DOESN'T YOU
KNOW.
WITH BEING CONFINED THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO ACCEPT THAT TREATMENT
SO EVERYTHING FROM THE
PREVENTION EARLY PENSION TO
CRISIS MANAGEMENT.
THOSE ARE THE SERVICES THAT WE
WOULD BE PROVIDING LPS BEDS AND
EXPANSION OF LPS BEDS --
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS WHEN
NECESSARY IN EXPANDING THOSE
SERVICES TO THE MENTALLY ILL
WITHIN THE JAIL POPULATION ALL
RIGHT SO -- SO I THINK THAT
FIRST OF ALL -- AND SAID THAT --
THE HOPE THE WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION I I GUESS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I I WANNA MAKE NOTE
IS THAT.
I AGREE WITH SENATOR UMBERG AND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS IN THE JAILS BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT.
THE PURPOSE OF THESE FUNDS.
WAS NOT TO AUGMENT AND SAY WELL
OUR JAIL POPULATION IS GROWING
AND SO WE NEED MORE MONEY AND WE
ALL LOOKED AT ME TO SAY.
THE PURPOSE OF AN HSA IS THE
MOVE THEM OUT OF JAIL.
SO -- SO WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- WELL THE CONCENTRATED
THERE NOW AND LOCK AND KEY AND
WE CAN MORE FOCUS ON THEM OKAY --
AT BUT I THINK THE PURPOSE IS TO
SO CAN YOU TELL ME HOW YOU PLAN
TO USE THE FUNDS TO HELP PEOPLE
GET OUT OF JAIL I REALIZE WE'RE
GIVING YOU SOME FLEXIBILITY SO
YOU CAN USE OF PEOPLE ARE IN
JAIL.
CELL BUT THE PURPOSE IS TO GET
THEM OUT RIGHT MAYBE I WOULD
ANSWER THAT BY WOULD THAT WOULD
HELP AND STAY OUT OF JAIL AFTER
BEING RELEASED.
OKAY THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT'S
ABOUT IS MAKING SURE THAT YOU
HAVE METS WHEN THEY'RE RELEASED
THERE'S A THERE'S A WHOLE RE
ENTRY PORTION TO THIS AS WELL
OKAY THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO HEAR
RIGHT HE'S ABOUT RE ENTRY RIGHT
SO YOU CAN START WHILE THEY'RE
IN THE JOBS RIGHT.
NOW YOU CAN'T YOU HAVE TO WAIT
TILL THEY'RE ACTUALLY OUT AND
YOU CAN'T LINK THEM UP JUST LIKE
A HOSPITAL THERE'S A DISCHARGE
PLAN THAT GOES ALONG WITH EVERY
INMATE THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
INCORPORATE INTO OUR SYSTEM.
SO WHEN THEY HIT THE STREET THEY
JUST DON'T GO BACK TO THEIR OLD
WAYS WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW OKAY ALL RIGHT SO -- I A
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE BILL BUT I
ALSO URGE THAT YOU WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION I THINK THE FOCUS ON
BASICALLY HOW DO YOU HELP PEOPLE
GET OUT TO THE TRANSITION PLAN
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO BILL
START WHILE THEY'RE IN THE JAIL
NOT HAVE TO WAIT.
BECAUSE THE RESTRICTION IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT I THINK
IS A GOOD THING -- BECAUSE WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GETTING
PEOPLE OUT OF JAIL AND THEN BE
SURE THEY CAN STAY OUT RIGHT
BECAUSE THAT'S THE GOLD
INITIATIVE WE DON'T WANT MORE
PEOPLE IN JAIL WANT FEWER PEOPLE
IN JAIL.
CELL -- I CERTAINLY HOPE TO HEAR
THAT THAT'S BEEN THE FOCUS OF
ANY SORT OF EFFORTS -- AND I
THINK -- PERHAPS THAT ALSO
SPEAKS A LITTLE TO THE CONCERN
OF THE OPPOSITION AS WELL SO --
SO IT DOES SO CERTAINLY -- WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO WE
CAN ACTUALLY MOVE THE BILL OR
ANYTHING BUT I HOPE THAT MAYBE
PERHAPS SO YOU CAN THEN YOUR
CLOTHES SPEAK -- TO WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION ON ADDRESSING
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES.
SO BUZZ THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'VE HEARD YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR I'VE HEARD YOUR POINT WITH
RESPECT TO SUPPLICATION I'VE
HEARD YOUR POINT AS TO WHAT ARE
WE DOING THIS GOING TO BE NEW
AND DIFFERENT.
RATHER THAN JUST DOING THE SAME
OLD TO MORE PEOPLE I THINK
THAT'S YOUR POINT AND AND I I IF
I'VE HEARD THAT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE DOING THINGS THAT ARE NEW
AND DIFFERENT -- SO THAT.
WE USE OUR BEST EFFORTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE THAT ARE IN JAIL
DON'T RETURN TO JAIL.
OKAY BUT THAT ORIGINAL VOCALS
AND THAT'S THAT THAT'S FINE NOW
YOU SHOULD OR SHOULDN'T I BUT WE
CAN'T GO YET BUT SENATOR SANDERS
HOUSES AND ARMOR AS ONE WHO --
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND GETTING THE
DISCUSSION STARTED AND I KNOW
YOUR YOU'RE YOU'RE A MAN OF YOUR
WORD YOU'RE GONNA WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND WE WANT TO GET
PEOPLE OUT OF JAIL AND AND AND
REDUCE THE RECIDIVISM RATE AND
GIVE THEM THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
THEY NEED IT I APPRECIATE THE
APPOINTED SHOOT YOUR PRODUCT BUT
I WANTED I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AND RESHAPE HER FORWARD.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION WHEN WE HAVE A
CARAMEL TAKE UP THE BILL FOR
ABOUT EIGHT THIRTY MEMBERS THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
ALRIGHT I SEE IS SOME A MEMBER
WOULD HERE WELCOME.
AND OKAY SO -- AND STAND YOU BY
WELL YOU HAVE MANY BILLS BEFORE
US BUT YOU ONLY HAVE TO YOU NEED
TO PRESENT. THREE OR ON CONSENT
SO -- WE WANT TO TAKE THEM UP
THE FILE ORDER.
OKAY SO WE'LL START OFF WITH A
NUMBER TO A BETWEEN.
TWO OH FOUR WELCOME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR -- DOCTOR DOCTOR PAN AND
AND MEMBERS -- EIGHTY TWO OH FOR
COMMUNITY BENEFITS ARE THE
SERVICES NONPROFIT HOSPITALS
PROVIDE TO ADDRESS COMMUNITY
NEEDS IN EXCHANGE FOR THEIR TAX
EXEMPT STATUS.
AND INCLUDE CHARITY CARE SUPPORT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS AND
DONATIONS OF FUNDS ARE RESOURCES
I CONTRIBUTE TO A COMMUNITY
PRIORITIES SUCH AS HOUSING.
HOWEVER THERE IS NO STANDARDIZED
REQUIREMENT FOR CALCULATING AND
REPORTING THE VALUE OF COMMUNITY
BENEFITS THIS MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR COMMUNITIES TO KNOW THE
VALUE OF THE COMMUNITY BENEFITS
BEING PROVIDED BY THE HOSPITAL.
A B. TWO OH FOUR REVISES
COMMUNITY BENEFIT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BY DEFINING CHARITY
CARE AND REQUIRING HOSPITALS
REPORT CHARITY CARE AT COST.
THE LAW ALSO REQUIRES SMALL AND
RURAL HOSPITALS THAT ARE PART OF
THE SYSTEM TO REPORT -- AND RICK
AND REQUIRES US PAD TO ANNUALLY
PREPARE A REPORT ON THE AMOUNT
EACH HOSPITAL SPENDS ON
COMMUNITY BENEFITS.
SPELT BILLS INTENDED TO ASSURE
THAT IS A HOT AS HOSPITAL SYSTEM
SYSTEMS GROW IN SIZE.
THE INDIVIDUAL HOSPITALS IN THE
SYSTEM REMAIN MEANINGFUL OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
WITH ME -- MARY JANE A MERRY
TUNE DHEAS WITH -- HEALTH ACCESS
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OKAY THANK
YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT.
AFTER YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
CENTERS AND JDS HERE ON BEHALF
OF HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA PLEASE
TO SUPPORT A B. TWO OH FOUR
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE ALL SPREAD
TO PUBLISH A REPORT AND HOW MUCH.
HOSPITAL SPENT ON COMMUNITY
BENEFIT WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS THAT DEFINE
CHARITY CARE WHICH REFLECTS THAT
TO CHARITY CARE.
IS GIVEN WITHOUT EXPECTATION OF
ANY COMPENSATION AND NOT AFTER
HUNTING PATIENCE FOR UNPAID
HOSPITAL BILLS OR SENDING THEM
TO COLLECTIONS FOR BAD DEBT.
LACK OF REPORTING OF THE ACTUAL
MONETARY VALUE OF COMMUNITY
BENEFIT INVESTMENT IS
PROBLEMATIC.
THIS IS BECAUSE POLICY MAKERS
AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES DO NOT
KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL VALUE IS OF
THE COMMUNITY BENEFITS BEING
PROVIDED IN EXCHANGE FOR THE
LOCAL HOSPITALS.
TAX EXEMPT STATUS WHILE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS MAY BE
EXPRESSIONS OF NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS CHARITABLE MISSION
THEY SHOULD ALSO SERVE AS
JUSTIFICATION FOR THEIR TAX
EXEMPT SHIN. EIGHTY TWO OH FOUR
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT
INSURERS TAX EXEMPT PRIVATE
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS ARE PROVING
THEIR WORTH AND ARE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING MEASURABLE COMMUNITY
BENEFITS. TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE EVEN AFTER THE
STATE'S IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ACA OR THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS REMAIN UNINSURED
AND MANY MORE ARE UNDER INSURED
AND CANNOT AFFORD THEIR HEALTH
CARE. FOR THESE REASONS WE
REQUEST YOUR IDOL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES A
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SERAPH LOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
OKAY SEEN OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
WE OFFER BRING ABOARD.
OKAY WELL.
EXCELLENT WELL THE EXCELLENT
BILL -- LOOKING FOR HAVING CORN
SO WE CAN VOTE ON IT WHICH I
LIKE THE CLOTHES.
AT THE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
IT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE A
OKAY THANK YOU ALRIGHT LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SIXTEEN FORTY
TWO THANK YOU AGAIN A CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- IN MARCH TWENTY
NINETEEN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR RELEASED A CRITICAL
AUDIT ON HOW WELL THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM PROVIDES PREVENTIVE CARE
TO CHILDREN.
WHICH IS.
APPARENTLY NOT VERY WELL -- THE
BILLABLE TO WOULD TAKE UP A
NUMBER OF STEPS TO
COMPREHENSIVELY ADDRESSED THE
PROBLEMS IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR BY ADDRESSING STATE
PAYMENT RATE PLAN RATES TO PLANS.
INCREASING THE PENALTIES FOR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND REQUIRING
PLANS TO ATTEMPT TO FIND A
CLOSER SPECIALIST WHEN
BENEFICIARIES HAVE TO TRAVEL
OUTSIDE THE GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
BUT ALSO REQUIRE AN OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION PROGRAM ON PREVENTIVE
SERVICES I'D LIKE TO TAKE I'D
LIKE TO TAKE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS -- SOME BUT NOT ALL
OF THE COUNTIES AND MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS CONCERNS THE
SERGEANTS ARE PASSING OUT A MOCK
UP A COUPLE OF THE MAJOR CHANGES
WORTH HIGHLIGHTING -- THE
AMENDMENT -- RECORD THAT WOULD
REQUIRE FOR THE PURPOSES OF A
REQUIREMENT THAT MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS MAKE THEIR
BEST EFFORT TO ESTABLISH A
MEMBER SPECIFIC CASE AGREEMENT.
WITH AN APPROPRIATE SPECIALIST
PROVIDER THE RATE -- TO BE THE
MEDICARE RATE FOR SERVICE RATE
OR ADMIT RATE MUTUALLY AGREED
UPON BETWEEN THE SPECIALIST AND
THE MEDICAL MEDICARE PLAN.
PLANS WOULDN'T HAVE TO HAVE TO
MEET THIS REQUIREMENT IF THE
PLAN HAS ATTEMPTED TO CONTRACT
WITH A SPECIALIST IN THE MOST
RECENT FISCAL YEAR.
AND ALSO ON THE PENALTY
PROVISIONS THE AMENDMENTS
REQUIRE THE DH CS DIRECTOR -- TO
DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF THE PENALTY -- BASED ON
MULTIPLE NONEXCLUSIVE FACTORS
AND ADD TO THE LIST OF ELEVEN
FACTORS THE DH CS IS REQUIRED TO
CONSIDER -- THE PREMISES -- THE
PREMISE OF THE OF THE BILL IS
SIMPLE THE TECH IS VERY
TECHNICAL IN NATURE -- ASPIRIN I
VOTE AND PLEASE BE KIND AND YOUR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WITNESSES ABOARD.
THE WIND AWAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
SUPPORT TO INSURE MEMBERS ARE
ABLE TO GET NEEDED.
CARE MEDIC HEALTH PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO MEET SET PROVIDER
TIME AND DISTANCE STANDARDS IT'S
VERY BY COUNTY AND POP UP
POPULATION DENSITY.
SOME PLANS ARE UNABLE TO MEET
THE STANDARDS WITH SOME FAMILIES
BEING EXPECTED TO TRAVEL OVER
SIX HOURS OR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILES ONE WAY TO SEE A IN
NETWORK SPECIALIST THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE PLANS UNABLE TO
MEET THOSE STANDARDS. TO ASSIST
AFFECTED MEMBERS AND REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO EVALUATE -- IF
PLANS REQUEST A LONGER TIME
EDISON STANDARDS IF THAT LONGER
TIME AND DISTANCE STANDARD IS
REASONABLE FROM THE CONSUMER
PERSPECTIVE.
WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE SELF
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES A
SUPPORT.
LINDA TERROR WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
AND VIDEOS WITH HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCER MAP THE CAPRI
CADMIUM FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND
SPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I
HAVE A BRIEF COMMENT IF THAT'S
OKAY.
VERY BRIEF BECAUSE WE TOOK
WITNESSES RIGHT OUT YEAH WE HAVE
AN OFFICIAL SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION ON THE CURRENT BILL IN
PRINT -- WE SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
MONITOR AND ENFORCE NETWORK
NETWORK ADEQUACY FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES ESPECIALLY FOR
CHILDREN AND PREVENTIVE SERVICES.
I AM HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT A WELL INTENTIONED POLICY
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
SPECIALISTS COULD NEGATIVELY
AFFECT THE WAY THE MANAGED CARE
PLANS CONTRACT WITH THOSE
PROVIDERS.
IF THE PLANS ARE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH PROLIFIC MEMBERS
SPECIFIC CASE AGREEMENTS.
IT COULD DISINCENTIVE EYES THE
PLANTS FROM ATTEMPTING TO
CONTRACT WITH THOSE SAME
SPECIALIST.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
BILL IN UPDATING OUR POSITION
WHEN IT'S IN PRINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT BUT THIS IS AN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME UP [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
RIGHT WELCOME -- MEMBERS CUT THE
MUSTARD WITH THE LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS -- JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THE AND THANK THE AUTHOR AND
STAFF COMMITTEE STAFF AND
PERSONAL STAFF AS WELL I'M FOR
WORKING WITH US WE STILL HAVE AN
OPPOSING LESS AMENDED POSITION.
WE JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
OUTSTANDING ISSUES BUT THE ITEMS
THAT THE AUTHOR CLEAR FIGHT ON
THE MIKE JUST NOW ARE INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL IN GETTING US TO A PLACE
OF NEUTRALITY POTENTIALLY
SUPPORT -- WE WILL WORK ON THAT
BUT WE JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT WE NEED
TO WORK ON THE WORK IN PROGRESS.
SO FOR NOW THOUGH OPPOSE LAST
MINUTE.
CONNIE DUNN GOT ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE TO HAVE
AN OPPOSING LESS AMENDED.
POSITION AND WE WOULD JUST LIKE --
TO THE URGE THE LEGISLATURE --
TO HELP.
SET.
TRANSPARENCY AND CLEARLY
DELINEATED STANDARDS SO THAT --
WE CAN WORK TOWARDS THOSE GOALS
WE'VE BEEN VERY IMPRESSED WITH
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE
BEEN HAVING AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION.
ANNA JENNIFER ALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS I'D LIKE -- TO YOU KNOW
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF THEY'VE
HAD A VERY OPEN DOOR.
PROCESS WITH THIS BILL WE'VE HAD
NUMEROUS MEETINGS AND LOTS OF
VERY SETS OF AMENDMENTS SINCE WE
JUST APPRECIATE THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US WE
ARE VERY CLOSE BUT THERE STILL
ARE SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES AND
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA MY APOLOGIES FOR
ARE THE LETTER WE REMAIN UP
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR ALL THE WORK THAT.
HAS GONE INTO THE BILL THUS FAR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS ARE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT SCENE NINE
SO A PERSONAL -- SIMILAR WHAT I
WANT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I ALWAYS -- TOLD
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
THAT -- THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
MEDIC COW SO EVEN THOUGH WE
CONTRACT OUT TO VARIOUS LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS AND OTHER TYPES OF
ENTITIES.
THAT THEY'RE DISPOSABLE ENTITY
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED THE
LEGISLATURE I KNOW YOU CHOOSE
SOME HEALTH COMMITTEE AS WELL
AND IT THEREFORE SUPPORT THAT
THEY HAVE THE TOOLS THEY NEED.
TO TO CARRY OUT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY -- SO THEY HOLD
CONTRACTED THEY NEGOTIATE
CONTRACT THEY NEED TO HAVE THOSE
TOOLS.
AND I THINK THAT AUDIT SHOWED
THAT - THERE THEY DEFINITELY
NEED TO EXERCISE OVERSIGHT AND
THEY NEED THE TOOLS TO DO THAT.
THIS BILL -- ADDRESSES THAT
ISSUE AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT YOU PAY FOR IT I ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE COMING
CELLS ARE YOU COMING CLOSE TO
THE OPPOSITION.
BUT AGAIN FUNDAMENTALLY -- THIS
IS ABOUT BE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT TO WE DON'T
HAVE WHAT WE SAW ON THAT OUT
RIGHT AS A PEDIATRICIAN WHO
ACTUALLY TAKES CARE MAINLY MEDI
CAL PATIENTS.
IT WAS QUITE DISAPPOINTED TO SEE
WHAT.
WHAT'S CAME OUT THAT AUDIT US A
CERTAINLY I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL WE STILL DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET -- BUT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THE ADJUSTER
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR FOR A VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME --
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS -- IS IT
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPLICATED
TECHNICAL ISSUES IN THE BILL
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND I THINK WE'RE
VERY CLOSE.
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SUMMER WHAT ARE.
EIGHT SEE I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
AUTHORS WE ALSO IF THERE'S ONE
OTHER MEMBERS CAN MAKE HERE WILL
GET A QUORUM.
IT WOULD TAKE SOMETHING OF THEIR
OWN
.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS.
REMIND THE AUTHORS OF THE SHOP
LATER DOES HEARING GOES LATER
LAST TIME WE WERE VERY COURTEOUS
AND ALLOWING PEOPLE TO TESTIFY
FOR OTHER PEOPLE BEFORE THE
HOLIDAY
-- ALL RIGHT I SEE
CENTER TACO -- SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO SELFISH
CORN.
CAN.
CAN HEAR STONE STONE HERE
GONZALES GONZALES HERE GROW
FURTADO FURTADO HERE LLEVA
MITCHELL.
JOE HERE MINING RUBIO.
HEY WE HAVE A QUORUM SO -- AS WE
WAIT FOR AUTHORS LET'S GO AHEAD
AND TAKE THE ROLE IN THE BILLS
THAT WE'VE HEARD -- SO -- FIRST
OF ITEM NUMBER ONE SP SIX SIX
FIVE BY CENTER -- BURKE IS THERE
A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER STONE --
SECTOR IS SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND HI.
I STONE STONE AIKENS HOLLIS
GONZALEZ I GROW FURTADO FURTADO
I LAY THAT MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I MORNING RUBIO.
THE BILL CREATES FIVE VOTES I
SEE A SUMMER GRAYSON WELCOME AND
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE NOTE THAT
YOU WAITED A VERY LONG TIME AND
END UP HAVING TO LEAVE SO BUT I
DID APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
I'M SORRY THAT BECAUSE WE TAKE
THINGS A FILE OR WE CAN.
GET BEFORE.
BUT YOU ARE HERE AND WE WANT.
I'M GLAD WE CAN GIVE YOU
DEPUTIES PRESENT NOW SO -- WE
HAVE LET'S SEE HERE BILLIONS FOR
FARMERS AND OKAY ITEM NUMBER
NINE EIGHTY SIX FIFTY ONE
WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB SIX FIFTY ONE WILL INCREASE
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
EMERGENCY ERR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS WITHOUT PASSAGE OF THE
LEGISLATION IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN REIMBURSEMENT.
WILL REVERT TO NINETEEN NINETY
THREE LEVELS EMERGENCY ERR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS ARE AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE STATEWIDE
EMS SYSTEM CURRENT META CAL
RATES PAY PROVIDERS FAR BELOW
THE RATE NEEDED. TO PROVIDE
THEIR SERVICES AB SIX FIFTY ONE
WILL RE BASED THE MEDI CAL RATE
FOR AIR AMBULANCE PROVIDERS TO
THE RULE MEDICARE LEVEL.
WHICH WILL BRING AIR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS CLOSER TO ACTUAL COST
IN DOING SO A B. SIX FIFTY ONE
WILL ENSURE AIR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS CAN CONTINUE PROVIDING
LIFE SAVING SERVICES TO
RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I DO HAVE WITNESSES HERE WITH
THE PERMISSION OF CHAIR TO SELF
INTRODUCE.
I THANK YOU WHEN THIS IS A PORT
SIX MINUTES MAX.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL
BRYANT -- REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF THEIR
MEDICAL SERVICES -- I'LL JUST BE
LARGELY HERE FIFTEEN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE BUT I JUST WANT TO
REALLY POINT OUT EMPHASIZE THAT
WERE ABOUT TO FALL OFF THE
FINANCIAL CLIFF.
THE SENSUALLY TEMPORARY FUNDING
SOURCE WE HAD WITH THE AMADA
PROGRAM THAT WAS THE FOUR DOLLAR
PENALTY ON MOVING VIOLATIONS
GOES AWAY DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
AND WITHOUT THAT AGAIN THE
FUNDING GETS VIRTUALLY CUT IN
HALF I THINK IT SETS BACK.
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
SO I'LL BE AROUND FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE THEM BUT
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE A CHIEF
WALLS WHITE -- TO GET THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
SENATOR PAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
WHAT WHITE FIRE CHIEF AMADOR
FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT?
OUR SPECIAL DEPENDENT DASH
DISTRICT COVERING FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY ONE SQUARE MILES OF AMBER
COUNTY-- ROUGHLY 85% OF THAT
COUNTY.
AN ERROR MEDICAL RESOURCES ARE
ABSOLUTELY VITAL FOR US TO
ACHIEVE THE POSITIVE PATIENT
OUTCOMES THAT WE ARE TODAY --
IT'S NOT JUST THE SPEED AT WHICH
WE CAN GET TO A PATIENT.
BUT HOW RAPIDLY WE CAN GET THAT
PATIENT TO THE DEFINITIVE CARE
THAT THEY NEED.
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES%
ALONE IN AMADOR COUNTY WITHOUT
THEIR MEDICAL TO GET THEM TO
THESE HOSPITALS.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE FIREFIGHTERS
THAT ARE ROUTINELY FIGHTING
FIRES IN THESE REMOTE RURAL
REGIONS OF THE OF THE STATE.
N..
SHOULD THEY BECOME INJURED --
DURING THOSE OPERATIONS IT'S
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL THAT THEY
RECEIVE QUICK RAPID TRANSPORT
AND CARE.
NOW EVERY.
I'M NOT UNLIKE ANY OTHER RURAL
COUNTY IN THE STATE AND FIRE
CHIEF THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION INCLUDE
IN CALIFORNIA METRO CHEESE.
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF CITIES.
THANK YOU AND GOOD SEE YOU AGAIN
G. BY.
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN SET ON
MON POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
MARTIN AT THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AM J. D. AS WOULD HELP ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRISTIAN GELLER
WITH ASSOCIATION OF OURMEDICAL
SERVICES REPRESENTING ALL OF
THEIR MEDICAL SERVICES IN THE
STATE STRONG SUPPORT AND URGENT
AND I VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BUT AFTERNOON ERIN **** A PH
HIGHER MEDICAL MANAGER BUSINESS
OPERATIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU --
MARTY ARCS IS RICHER MEDICAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GEOFF KRESGE OUR REGIONAL
DIRECTOR CLINICAL OPERATIONS FOR
RICHER MEDICAL SERVICES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I THINK IT'S A MARIN FLIGHT
NURSE FOR PH AEROMEDICAL IN
SPORT THANK YOU.
JEFFREY TURNS FLIGHT NURSE PH I.
R. MEDICAL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEFF FROM PH I. AEROMEDICAL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICOLE RICHARDS FLIGHT NURSE
REACHER MEDICAL AND SUPPORT.
CRIME AND AS PROGRAM DIRECTOR
REGIONAL MEDICAL SERVICES THAT
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AFTER LOSSES GOT CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SPORT
THANK YOU.
FAITH FOR JUST THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
UNDERWRITERS IN CALIFORNIA
SENSATION JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SIR FLOCKSCALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DOMINIC TOMORROW HERE ON BEHALF
OF THEIR METHODS A PROVIDER WITH
BASES AROUND THE STATE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BIG LOSERS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- YES CENTER SO I THINK
IT WAS SURE I WANT TO JUST --
REALLY -- PRES -- SOME INCREASE
IN FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
AND SHE FLIGHT I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE AND SAID SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE THESE AVIATION
PARAMEDICAL SERVICES.
NOT JUST IN A RULER IN WHICH I
DO REPRESENT SOME RURAL AREAS
LIKE IDLEWILD CALIFORNIA BUT MY
WIFE AND I WERE INVOLVED IN A
VERY SERIOUS -- VEHICLE ACCIDENT
ON THE NINETY ONE FREEWAY.
AND IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE.
WITH A PEAK HOUR TRAFFIC TO GET
AN AMBULANCE THERE.
SO THEY ACTUALLY CLOSE THIS ONE
OF THE BUSIEST FREEWAYS IN THE
COUNTRY DOWN AND AND LANDED A
HELICOPTER RIGHT NEXT.
TO MY WIFE AND TRANSPORTED HER
TO THE HOSPITAL WHICH IT HAD A
GOOD HAVE A GOOD OUTCOME
ALTHOUGH ALBEIT VERY SERIOUS SO --
WELL WITHOUT THIS BILL -- WE
CAN'T EXPECT THESE EXPENSIVE
OPERATORS TO STAY IN BUSINESS.
THIS COULD BE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT VOTE SO WE TAKE THIS
YEAR BECAUSE HE'S THIS BILL WAS
GOING TO SAVE PEOPLE'S LIVES
SOME WOMEN.
AND SO I APPLAUD YOU FOR
BRINGING FORWARD -- I WOULD LOVE
TO BE A CALL HAVE HER IF IT'S
NOT TOO LATE TO GET ON THERE BUT
KNOW YOUR CHAMPION MY APPRECIATE
YOUR BRINGING FORWARD AND ALL BE
EVERY MOVE IT AT THE RIGHT TIME.
IF YOU ARE A SINNER TANTO.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ECHO.
IN A STATEMENT BY MY COLLEAGUE --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TWO FOR
TAKING THE SIGN AND THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE ON THIS BILL.
IF THERE'S STILL ROOM AND AND
TIME AVAILABLE TO JUMP ON AS A
CO AUTHOR I WOULD LOVE -- TO AND
BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE.
DONE ON THIS.
I'D SEEN OTHER QUESTIONS --
THROUGH A VERY IMPORTANT -- I
ALSO WANT US SECOND THIRD MY
COLLEAGUES -- AND STATEMENTS --
SO THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ABSOLUTELY THERE'S PLENTY OF
ROOM IN TIME. FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND ABOUT
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER STONE THE
MOTIONS TO PASS REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. SIX
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN BUY AN ICE STONE.
THIS STONE.
CONSOLIDATE GONZALEZ I'D GROWN
HER TALK.
TO HER TITLE I LLEVA MITCHELL
MINING RUBIO.
AFL CURLY AS FOUR VOTES WILL PUT
THE ROLE ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SAYS IT WAS RUNNING
AROUND BUT LOOK.
FOR TO CLOSING ROLE LATER OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU.
RIGHT I SEE YOU SENT THANK YOU.
I SEE SOME A REMAND SHINE
WELCOME AND SO YOU HAVE A TWO
ITEMS BUT ONES ON CONSENT SO.
WE HAVE ITEM TYSON WILL TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY A. B..
TWELVE FORTY NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS -- AT AS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE IN MOCK UP FORM AND
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND IN PARTICULAR AT THE
CHAIR FOR HIS WORK.
MAYBE TWELVE FORTY NINE
REPRESENTS AN INNOVATIVE%
APPROACH TO CONTAIN SKYROCKETING
HEALTHCARE COSTS.
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS TO THEIR EMPLOYEES
STRUGGLE TO CONTAIN COSTS AND
OBTAIN THE BEST QUALITY OF CARE.
THERE IS A GROWING MOVEMENT
ACROSS THE NATION TO PERRIN
PLAYER HEALTH BENEFIT PLANS WITH
ORGANIZED INTEGRATED PROVIDERS
IN A MORE ALIGNED RELATIONSHIP
TO PRODUCE BETTER CARE AT LOWER
COST.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE TWO
PILOTS ONE IN THE SOUTHERN
PORTION OF THE STATE AND THE
OTHER IN THE NORTHERN PORTION
THAT WOULD OPERATE FOR A PERIOD
OF FIVE YEARS.
THE PILOTS WOULD INCLUDE RISK
BEARING PROVIDERS THAT ARE
MONITORED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE FOR
FINANCIAL SOLVENCY.
AND AND OPERATION SELF FUNDED
EMPLOYER PLANS WOULD USE WRIST
BASED PAYMENT MECHANISMS WITH
THE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. FOR
THEIR SERVICES RATHER THAN PURE
FEE FOR SERVICE COMPENSATION.
A STUDY BY THE UC BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PREDICTED THIS TYPE OF MODEL
COULD REDUCE HEALTHCARE
EXPENDITURES BY AN ESTIMATED ONE
HUNDRED AND TEN BILLION DOLLARS
OVER TEN YEARS.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES
PROTECTION FOR CONSUMERS LANE ON
A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMPONENTS SUCH AS
ACCESS TO SPECIALISTS
PRESCRIPTION BENEFITS AND A
COMPLAINTS PROCESS THAT MUST BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS. FOR THE
PILOT PROGRAMS.
CONTAINING THE RISING COST OF
HEALTHCARE REQUIRES A NEW WAY OF
THINKING THIS PILOT-- THE
PROJECT WILL AUTHORIZED BY THIS
BILL CAN CHANGE THE WAY WE
APPROACH HEALTHCARE DELIVERY.
HERE WITH ME JUST A TAD TESTIFY
ARE SEVERAL PEOPLE -- BUT TYPE
FIRST OFFICE IN THE MARTIN THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
RIGHT TO WITNESSES THE ARMY
WITNESSES ARE SPEAKING.
OKAY SO JUST KEEP IN MIND SIX
MINUTES TOTAL FOR US AND I SEE A
LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE TO
REMIND PEOPLE DON'T USE OF ALL
THE TIME.
FOR TWO OTHER PEOPLE OKAY
WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN DOCTOR PAN AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIGHT MEAN SHINE
FOR ALLOWING US TO ADDRESS YOU
TODAY I'M CINDY MARTIN
SUPERINTENDENT OF SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS AS THE FIFTH
LARGEST EMPLOYER IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
WITH MORE THAN SIXTEEN THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES WE SPEND ALMOST TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH ON
HEALTHCARE FOR OR TWO HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
EMPLOYEE HEALTH AND WELLNESS IS
A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF OUR
ABILITY TO OFFER HIGH QUALITY
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
IN OUR COMMUNITY IN ADDITION TO
MY DAY JOB I SERVE AS A
MANAGEMENT CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS VOLUNTARY
EMPLOYEES BENEFIT ASSOCIATION OR
V. BUFFER SHORT.
BIT BUT WAS STARTED IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE THROUGH THE
COMBINED EFFORTS OF SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENTS AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION.
AS WELL AS OTHERS THE BOOK
PROVIDES HEALTH CARE BENEFITS
FOR EDUCATION MUNICIPAL AND PUT
PUBLIC AGENCY EMPLOYEES AND IS
REGULATED AS A NONPROFIT TRUST
UNDER IRS CODE SECTION. FIVE OH
ONE C. NINE WE HAVE A CLEAR
MISSION AT VIVA THROUGH
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIPS WE
PROVIDE HEALTHCARE RESOURCES
THAT ARE EFFECTIVE AFFORDABLE
AND OF THE HIGHEST QUALITY AND
VALUE TO OUR PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEES.
AS BOARD CHAIR I ALONG WITH MY
FIFTEEN FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS
ACTORS FIDUCIARY STORMED INTO
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS WE TAKE THIS
DUTY VERY SERIOUSLY AS WE WORK
TO DEVELOP THE HIGHEST QUALITY
PROGRAMS.
IN THE STATE BY LAW VBO FINDS
MAY ONLY BE USED TO THE BENEFIT
OF OUR TRUST MEMBERS UNLIKE EVEN
NONPROFIT HEALTH PLANS THERE'S
NO ONE PROFITING NO DISTRIBUTION
OF EARNINGS IN EXCESS RESERVES
MAY NOT BE RETURNED TO ANY
EMPLOYEES.
WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS BECAUSE THAT'S
OUR PRIMARY MISSION TO SERVE
INDIVIDUAL TRUST MEMBERS.
MR CHERRY MEMBER SCOTT WHICH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE COVERAGE THE
PATRIOTS COUNCIL THE WESTERN
SEAS COUNCIL SHEET METALWORKERS
TO CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
IN THE ST BUILDING TRADES OR NOT --
PRESENT TODAY.
WE OPERATE AS YOU KNOW TAFT
HARTLEY TRUST FUNDS THAT SIMILAR
TO VIVA RISA PREEMPTED -- UNION
TRUST FUNDS THAT FOR DECADES AND
DECADES HAVE DIRECTLY CONTRACTED
WITH PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE THE
BEST AND HIGHEST QUALITY HEALTH
CARE AT THE LOWEST COST POSSIBLE
TO OUR MEMBERS.
WITH THIS BILL WILL DO IS ALLOW
A VERY.
UNIQUE PILOT PROGRAM TO ALLOW US
TO GO OUT AND CONTINUE TO DIRECT
CONTRACT IN WE HAVE ONE TRUST
FUND CONTINUED TO GO OUT IN
DIRECT CONTRACT BUT ON A
CAPITATED BASIS. TO SEE WHAT
TYPE OF COST SAVINGS WE CAN GO
OUT AND GET IN THE MARKET PLACE
BY OUR OWN DIRECT CONTRACTING
REDUCING ADMINISTRATION COSTS
REDUCING COST OR EMPLOYERS.
AS WELL AS THE OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSES TO OUR MEMBERS WE WANT
TO THANK THE STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE AND FOR THE CHAIRMAN
FOR WORKING ON THIS WITH US AND
PROFOUND PROVIDING THE LEVEL OF
PROTECTIONS WE THINK THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE.
AND WE WOULD TO ANSWER YOUR
THANK YOU.
ARE EITHER WOULDN'T FOLLOW AND
WITH WE STILL HAVE TIME.
NOW WE CAN TELL YOU HAVE STILL --
YOU DO HAVE A LITTLE MORE TIME
IF SOMEONE ELSE WANTS
[inaudible]
TO OKAY.
THERE I THINK WHERE THEY'RE
AVAILABLE ANSWER QUITE A ALL
RIGHT NOW THAT WE DO GIVE PEOPLE
TIME THAT BUT WE ALSO SAVE YOU
WANT TAKE LESS WE DON'T MIND
THAT EITHER.
OKAY -- OTHER WITNESSES A
SUPPORT.
ERIC PARKER THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HEY DEXTER VICE PRESIDENT LEMON
GROVE SCHOOL BOARD.
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION REGION
SEVENTEEN AND CO CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS BE BUT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THEIR FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SHE ANY OTHER SPORT AT THE TABLE.
THE BILL BARCELONA WITH
AMERICA'S VISION GROUP -- CO
SPONSOR IN IN SUPPORT OKAY THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND IF YOU CAN PLEASE
MAKE ROOM FOR THE OPPOSITION
PLEASE AT THE TABLE.
IF I MIGHT MISTER CHAIR BETH
CAPELL ON BEHALF OF HEALTH TEXAS
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BEEN OPPOSED
TO LESS AMENDED POSITION.
WE'VE NEVER OPPOSE THE PILOT
PROJECT WHAT WE OPPOSED WAS
EXEMPTING THE RESTORING MEDICAL
GROUPS FROM THE MANY CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN THE KNOX KEEN ACT
THAT WE HAVE FOUGHT SO LONG AND
SO HARD.
FOR WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO SEE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED IN THIS COMMITTEE.
AND ANTICIPATE THE ONCE WE SEE
THE BILL THE COUNT LEDGE COUNCIL
VERSION OF THIS.
LANGUAGE THAT WE WILL BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION FORMALLY.
OKAY SO ALL RIGHT WELL WE'LL GO
AND RESTART THE CLOCK FOR THE
ACTUAL OPPOSITION AND BUT YOU
HAVE TO TAKE ALL SIX MINUTES WE
DON'T WANT TO GO RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK I WILL BE --
MISTER CHAIR -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURRS NICK LOUISE US ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS --
WE HAVE RECEIVED A DRAFT VERSION
OF THE AMENDMENT SO -- YOU KNOW
WERE WERE THAT I'M TAKING OUR
TIME TO ANALYZE THOSE.
I THINK YOU KNOW LIKE VIS A
PREVIOUS SPEAKER UNIT WE
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO SEE THE FINAL
VERSION OF THAT IN FRANCE AND
FOR WHAT WE CAN TELL US -- YOU
KNOW THE AMENDMENTS DO YOU
INTEND TO FILE OFF SOME OF THE
THE ROUGHER EDGES.
OF OF OF THE BILL FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE -- BUT WE DO HAVE A
STREET OPPOSE POSITION ON THE
BILL IN PRINT TO BE FAIR AND I
THINK IT'S BASED ON A
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE.
YOU KNOW IT LOOKS LIKE A HEALTH
PLAN ACTS LIKE A HEALTH PLAN THE
NEEDS TO FALL THE SAME RULES --
AS A HEALTH PLAN IN SO -- YOU
KNOW WHEN WE LOOK AT BILLS LIKE
THIS THAT EXAM TO OTHER ENTITIES
FROM PROVISIONS OF THE KNOX KEEN
ACT YOU KNOW FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THAT -- CREATES
UNFAIR COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGES --
YOU KNOW AGAINST MY MEMBERSHIP
WHICH HAS TO COMPLY WITH A
PRETTY RIGOROUS SET OF RULES
REGULATIONS AND LAWS -- YOU KNOW
THAT PROTECTS CONSUMERS AND
PROTECTS THE MARKET -- AND SO
YOU KNOW AMONG OTHER THINGS HE
OBVIOUSLY HEALTH PLANS HAVE TO
YOU KNOW PROVIDE.
YOU A FULL PANOPLY OF OF
BENEFITS AND SERVICES UNDER THE
LAW AND HERE TO FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY REQUIREMENTS -- TIMELY
ACCESS IN OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT
MATTERS OF LAW -- NEAR THE BILL
INFRINGES REMOVES SOME OF THOSE
PROTECTIONS -- AS IT CURRENTLY
STANDS -- WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT
THE AMENDMENTS ONCE THE BILLS IN
FRANCE AND YOU PROVIDE FURTHER
COMMENT AT THAT POINT BUT YOU
KNOW I DID AT THIS POINT IN TIME
WERE OPPOSED.
TO THE BILL -- AS IT'S CURRENTLY
IN PRINT SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
A MICROPHONE.
BUT SEVENTY WORKING ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES WE TOO ARE IN
OPPOSITION WE LANARK COMMENTS
WITH MY COLLEAGUE WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT REMOVING ANY
POTENTIAL PATIENT -- CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS BUT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
I'D SEEN OTHER WITNESSES --
QUESTIONS A COMMITTEE MEMBER
CENTER STONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I CERTAINLY.
SUPPORT PILOT PROGRAMS BY
SPECIALLY SO MANY -- GROUPS THAT
SEEK TO MAYBE DO BUSINESS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY AND LOWER
COSTS FOR THEIR MEMBERSHIP YOU
KNOW WE ALWAYS USED.
TO AT THE OPEN ENROLLMENT YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH HOW MUCH OUR
HEALTH CARE IN A CALL NOW.
SO FROM ONE ONE APPLAUD YOU FOR
FOR BRINGING AUTHORITY THE
STICKING POINT FOR ME WAS THE
EXEMPTION FROM THE KNOX KEEN.
SO COULD YOU JUST CLARIFY THAT --
YOU ACCEPT AN AMENDMENT CAN YOU
JUST.
BRIEFLY TELL TELL US WHAT THAT
AMOUNT IS WE HAVE ACCEPTED THAT
THAT AMENDMENT ALL I ASK AT MR
WATCH TO TO CHECK ON THAT.
YES.
SO I'M GONNA GET IN BEHALF OF
ALL THE TAFT HARTLEY TRUST FUNDS
THAT I REPRESENT WE THINK THAT
THE COMEDIAN AMENDMENT STRIKES A
GOOD BALANCE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE.
YOU KNOW ART TAFT CHARLIE TRUST
FUNDS ARE RISA PRINTED SO WE'RE
NOT SUBJECT TO ANY OF THE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN THE KNOX
KEEN ACT.
BECAUSE RUMORS THAT PRINTED IN
BECAUSE IT'S A REPRESENTED WORK
FORCE YOU KNOW IT IS INCUMBENT
UPON US TO LOOK AFTER THE THE
BEST INTERESTS OF OUR MEMBERS OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS THEY GET
A VOTE.
IN SO FOR THAT REASON -- WE
BELIEVE THAT -- WE PROVIDE MORE
THAN AMPLE PROTECTIONS TO OUR
MEMBERS SAID WE'VE DONE DONE A
GOOD JOB SINCE THE THIRTIES --
BUT THE COMMITTEE I THINK IS
STRUCK A GOOD BALANCE BETWEEN
PROVIDING SOME MINIMAL -- FLOORS
A TO SOME OF THOSE PROTECTIONS
BUT AT THE SAME TIME MAXIMIZING
THE FLEXIBILITY SO WE CAN TRY.
TO ACHIEVE THE COST SAVINGS
THROUGH UNIQUE BENEFITS DESIGNED
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
AND ARE THERE ANY YOU ARE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN THE
BILL -- TO KEEP THE LEGISLATURE
PRIZES TO THE HOPEFULLY THE
SUCCESSES THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
HAVING TO THIS PART OF PROGRAMS.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY IN FACT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
TO MAKE THOSE A LITTLE BIT MORE
ROBUST SO WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S JUST NOT IT'S THAT THE DATA
IS ALL THAT IT SHOULD BE.
OKAY AGAIN THANKS TO THE THE
AUTHOR APPRECIATE ALSO MISTER
BARCELONA'S EDUCATING MY OFFICE
ON ON THE BILL.
AND LOOKING FOR TO SUPPORTING IT
TODAY.
THANK YOU. FOR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OF SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS AT
SWANSEA'S FIRST BY ONE THANK THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH -- THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND MYSELF ON THE BILL YOU
KNOW WE WE WANT -- TO PROMOTE
INNOVATION -- BUT INNOVATION
CAN'T BE AT THE EXPENSE OF
PATIENTS AND AIDS -- DO I
RECOGNIZE THAT -- WE'RE WORKING
WITH ENTITIES THAT -- FIRST OF
ALL READY PART OF A RISA.
AND SO WITH ISN'T IT SO -- AND
ALSO THAT -- YOU'LL HAVE A
LONGSTANDING HISTORY OF TAKING
CARE OF MEMBERS OF THE
REPRESENTED WORK FOR SO THAT THE
ACTUAL.
RECIPIENTS ARE ALSO PART OF THE
GOVERNANCE AND BEEN ANYWAYS
BECAUSE OF THAT.
BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THOSE
WERE -- SHIFTING FROM A CONTRACT
FOR YOUR CONTRACTING WITH
PROVIDERS ON THE FEEL FREE FOR
SERVICE BASIS TO A CAPITATED
BASIS.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A CLEAR LINE
RESPONSIBILITY ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED SO WHAT HAPPENS IF
SOMEONE MAKES A CAPITATED
AGREEMENT.
AND IT TURNS OUT THEY MADE SOME
BAD DECISIONS AND NOW THE GROUP
OR WHATEVER SAYS OH WELL YOU
KNOW WE CAN'T MAKE IT WORK
TOGETHER.
WE DON'T WANT.
PATIENTS GETTING STUCK IN THE
MIDDLE SO WE'VE HAD SITUATIONS
WHERE WE'VE HAD CAPITATED
ENTITIES WHO MAY HAVE MADE BAD.
BUSINESS DECISIONS THERE OR
WHATEVER ACTUARY WEARABLE DIDN'T
WORK IT OUT AND NOW THEY FOUND
THEMSELVES AT THE WRONG END OF
THE STICK.
AND EITHER THEY CAN'T KEEP GOING
OR THEY DON'T WANT TO KEEP GOING
AND PEOPLE BAIL RIGHT AND THEN
WHAT HAPPENS.
SO WE CAN HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
ONE GROUP SAYS YOU KNOW WHAT
WITH A CONTRACT IS JUST TAKE
CARE OF THE OTHER ONES AS WE
CAN'T -- WE WANT.
AND AND AND WHILE WE'RE BATTLING
THAT OUT PATIENTS CAN GET CARE
AND SO I APPRECIATE AGAIN --
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THAT BE SURE WE HAVE FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY STANDARDS BECAUSE THIS
IS ABOUT TRANSFERRING RISK
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN JUST
SAYING WHAT YOU DO SURGERY I'LL
PAY YOU X. AMOUNT.
NOW THIS IS A CAPITATION THERE'S
RISK INVOLVED AND SO APPRECIATE
THOSE PROTECTIONS -- WHILE STILL
TRYING TO PROTECT THE
FLEXIBILITY.
TO ALLOW YOU TO DO SOMETHING
THAT DAY KIND OF INNOVATION AND
ALSO JUST TO MAKE -- MENTION AS
WELL AS THAT -- THIS ASPILOTS
SO WE'RE REQUIRING AN EVALUATION
BY TEAMMATES SEE WHICH BY THE
WAY IS FUNDED BY THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE DOING THE PILOTS SELLING
UNTIL THE V. AND A GOOD THEY'RE
THEY'RE PAYING FOR THE VALUATION
AS WELL.
SO -- THIS SO THERE WILL BE AS
WE'LL BE ABLE TO SEE HOW THIS
WORKS OUT AND HOPEFULLY IT'S
EXCESS FULL AND WE CAN.
THAT THIS EFFORT CAN CONTINUE SO
CERTAINLY I'M IN SUPPORT OF BILL
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AT AND THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION AT THE END OF THE DAY
A B. TWELVE FORTY NINE IS ABOUT
BETTER CARE AT LOWER COST. FOR
WORKING FAMILIES THIS WILL
PROVIDE BETTER TOOLS TO MANAGE
HEALTHCARE SPENDING AND AND AS
HAS BEEN SAID WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A VERY SOPHISTICATED --
KIND OF POOL BUT EVEN WITH THAT
THERE ARE VERY STRONG CONSUMER
FOR TIONS HERE -- AND FINALLY IT
IS A PILOT PROGRAM AND WILL BE
ABLE TO SEE THE DATA AND SEE THE
RESULTS AND AND AS A LEGISLATURE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD FROM THERE --
MAKE SOME EDUCATED
DETERMINATIONS FROM THAT FROM
THAT DATA AND I WOULD DIE THANK
YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN
SPECTER REQUESTED MY VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU IS THERE A MOTION
ON THIS BILL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SERRA
GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
HAND HI.
I STONE.
STONE I GONZALES GONZALES I GROW
HER TACO. FOR TITLE I LLEVA
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I MINING RUBIO.
RUBIO HI.
THAT BILL HAS SIX VOTES
CURRENTLY WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THAT'S ENOUGH
LET'S GET IT OUT THANKS SO MUCH
MISTER THANK YOU.
I SEE AS A MEMBER FONT -- HERE.
AND YOU HAVE WHAT COMPANY YOU
HAVE THREE BILL SHOW JUST TAKE
THEM AND FOLLOW ORDERS.
OKAY SO LET'S START OFF WITH I
AND NUMBER.
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR FOURTEEN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
AND STAFF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
AS OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
DECISION TO TO ZERO OUT THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY IS
PROJECTED TO RESULT IN A
1-005-000-0214 FIFTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL [inaudible]
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT HEALTH
COVERAGE BY TWENTY TWENTY THE
RECENT BUDGET PROPOSAL IN SB
SEVENTY EIGHT RECOGNIZES THIS
CONCERN IT INCLUDES A STATE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY WHICH
PROVIDES IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIANS AND PREVENTS
FURTHER DESTABILIZATION.
OF THE INSURANCE MARKET A BEFORE
WHEN FOR WHAT IS SURE THAT THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS DATA. TO
INFORM THE LEGISLATURE REGARDING
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE INCLUDING
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS PAYING
THE PENALTY THE OTAL AMOUNT OF
STATE PENALTY IMPOSED AND THE
NUMBER OF EXEMPTIONS APPLIED.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION
ESPECIALLY AFTER I'VE -- THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY MERRY JUNE
DHEAS WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA HEY WELCOME.
HEATHER AND JDS HERE WOULD
HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA PIECES
SUPPORT AB FOUR ONE FOUR WHICH
IS THE REPORTING BILL TO TRACK
AND MONITOR DATA ON WHICH
CALIFORNIANS AND UP PAYING.
pAT THE STATE LEVEL HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED IMPOSING A
STATE LEVEL MANDATES.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE PENALTY
REVENUES.
WERE USED TO MAKE INDIVIDUAL
COVERAGE MORE AFFORDABLE.
THE NEWLY ENACTED CALIFORNIA
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE WILL ALSO
EXAM LOW INCOME PEOPLE --
COMPARED TO THE FEDERAL PENALTY
BECAUSE IT USES OUR CALIFORNIA
TAX FILING THRESHOLDS WHICH HAS
A HIGHER -- THRESHOLD THE DATA
REPORTING WILL BE IMPORTANT IN
ORDER FOR US TO MAKE COMPARISONS
WITH THE FEDERAL INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE.
HAVING THIS INFORMATION IS
ESSENTIAL AND KNOWING AND BETTER
UNDERSTANDING THE POPULATIONS
THAT PAY THE PENALTY WHICH CAN
THEN BE USED TO ASSESS OUT AT
THE IMPACTS OF THE PENALTY. FOR
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT REQUEST
YOUR IDOL THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
THIS FEATURE THIS FEATURE
MEMBERS NANCY TRY TO SPIN OFFS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BEING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. TWO MEN
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND SPORT
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS IN THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
IN SUPPORT HE BRENT SPENCER
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA PODI AFTER
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND SUPPORT.
HIM.
DARIA GREW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ON BEHALF OF
THE ALLIANCE OF CATHOLIC HEALTH
CARE AND SUPPORT YOU.
A DAY BEGINS US WITH AMERICA'S
VSION GROUPS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT ARE THEY WHAT THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
SE NON QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SINGER -- EIGHT OKAY
THERE'S A MOTION FROM CENTER
TADO -- SUBURBAN TO I THINK.
PRE BUILT -- FOLLOW UP -- YOU
WOULD DO IS CLOSE.
AS I THINK WE WE DID THE HARD
WORK IN THE BUDGET AND
APPRECIATED THE DISCUSSION WE
HAD LEADING UP TO THEM THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT PIECE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION
TO MONITOR WHAT'S HAPPENING MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS AS NECESSARY RESPECT
THE ASTEROID BELT.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER TYLER THE
MOTIONS TO PASSES AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING ON THE COMMITTEE --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI AND I STONE.
STONE NOW GONZALES GONZALES HIGH
GROWTH.
HER TADO HER TITLE I LABOR
MITCHELL.
SO I MINING RUBIO.
RUBIO HI. FIVE EIGHT CURRENT
LOTUS FIVE ONE THERE'S ENOUGH TO
ALL OF US TO GET OUT THERE HOLD
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY
THANK YOU.
AB FIFTY FIFTY WOULD EXTEND THE
TIME A PERSON CAN RECEIVE
SERVICES AT A CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNIT FROM TWENTY
FOUR HOURS TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS.
AND WHAT STEPS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS ARE CENTERS
THAT PROVIDE KEY SHORT TERM
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
UNDERGOING A MENTAL HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
HOWEVER THE CURRENT TWENTY FOUR
HOUR LIMITATION AT THESE
FACILITIES OFTEN FORCES
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKERS TO
STOP CARE FOR THEIR PATIENTS
BEFORE THEY ARE STABILIZED.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IT TAKES AN
AVERAGE OF TWENTY NINE POINT ONE
FIVE HOURS OF STABILIZATION
SERVICES TO STABILIZE.
AN ADULT THIS MEANS THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS ARE OFTEN NOT FULLY
STABILIZING OFTEN RETURN TO
EMERGENCY ROOM THE EMERGENCY
ROOM WITH A MORE DIRE SITUATION
WHICH LEADS TO INCREASED HEALTH
COSTS. FOR THE PUBLIC -- THE
STORES RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT UP TO NOW NO NOVO TO NO
OPPOSITION UP TO NOW WITHOUT A
RESPECT AFTER I VOTE -- WE ARE
WITH ME TO SUPPORT IS ADRIAN
SHELTON FROM THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE OKAY WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ADRIAN CHILTON WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE WE ARE PROUD
TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
FIFTY TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK IN ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
ON THIS CRITICAL MEASURE.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY WOULD START
WOULD ALLOW CERTIFIED CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO CLIENTS BE BEYOND
THE CURRENT TWENTY FOUR HOUR
TIME FRAME.
AN INCREASE THAT TIME'S UP TO UP
TO THIRTY SIX HOURS.
THESE FACILITIES PROVIDE A GREAT
DEAL OF ASSISTANCE TO OUR STATE --
NOT JUST AND HELPING ALLEVIATE
EMERGENCY ROOM OVERCROWDING IN
ASSISTING FIRST RESPONDERS BUT
ALSO ENSURING THAT PEOPLE
RECEIVE THE CARE THAT THEY
NEEDED A MORE APPROPRIATE
HEALING SETTING FOR SOMEBODY IN
A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT INVESTMENT IN
THESE FACILITIES OF THE UP AND
UP MOST IMPORTANCE AND EXTENDING
THAT TIME THE INDIVIDUALS CAN
REMAIN THERE WILL ALLOW FOR MORE
SEAMLESS LINKAGE -- INTO THE
COMMUNITY SO WE BELIEVE THIS
FRAMEWORK IS A LONG WAY IN THE
BILL TO MORE APPROPRIATELY
SERVING CLIENTS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR EITHER THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT FUNNY DELGADO ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WITH THE
RECENT SET OF AMENDMENTS WE
MOVED TO FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
OR SO I CAN JUST HEAR ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
SUPPORT IN CITY OF SANTA MONICA
THANK YOU.
GERALD SOFTEN THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR WE'RE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYWAY THIS IS AN OPPOSITION.
WE'LL SEE SEEN UNDER THE MOTIONS
OR ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OKAY.
WELL ANOTHER EXCELLENT BILL AND
THAT CERTAINLY VERY IMPORTANT
IMPROVE ACCESS MAN HOUSE YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THIS RESPECT WE ASK DR -- THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER SO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS ZACHARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI I'M STONE STONE I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROW FURTADO.
RETIRED -- I LABOR MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I AM MINING RUBIO
[inaudible]
HI. SIX THE BILLS CURRENTLY SIX
ZERO ENOUGH VOTES TO GET IT OUT
BUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
TRAPS MEMBERS AND FINALLY WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB.
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO CREATE AN INTER.
GOVERNMENTAL TRANSFER PROGRAM OR
I. G. T. FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES
THAT PROVIDE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES WHICH
ALLOWED THOSE PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL DOLLARS TO
OFFSET THE COST OF PROVIDING.
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES AND THIS IS A FOLLOW UP
TO S. B. TWENTY THREE BY --
SENATOR HERNANDEZ AND ACTED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH
ESTABLISHED A QUALITY ASSURANCE
FEE FOR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PROVIDERS OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES IN HOPE
OF DRAWING DOWN FEDERAL DOLLARS
TO OFFSET THE ACTUAL COST OF
PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES HOWEVER
ONCE.
DH CS RAN THE NUMBERS THAT Q. A.
F. PRESENTED UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES
THIS IS OUR ATTEMPT TO FIX THOSE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
AND WITH ME TODAY -- IN SUPPORT
I HAVE SHIFTED PETERSON DEPUTY
CHIEF OF ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
SOUTHERN MARIN FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL.
WELCOME.
A DARK PAINTING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION FIRE
DISTRICTS OF KIDS CESSATION
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW US TO DRIVE
DOWN MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT
WILL BE USED AT ST -- COUNTY AND
SPECIAL DISTRICT FIRE
DEPARTMENTS TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY IN THE CITIZENS THAT
WE THAT WE DO AND THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU SEE IN FRONT
OF YOU ARE FROM WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES --
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVER.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT.
HE THANK YOU TURN SENATORS JOHN
ACIDITY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE MOTIONS.
OF IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
STONE -- SO AGAIN I THANK YOU
FOR THIS BILL I ACTUALLY WITH%
THE HOUSE OF ASSEMBLY AUTHORED
REGIONAL BUILD THAT TO ALLOW THE
DRAW DOWN I KNOW WE CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT TO TRY TO
MAXIMIZE OUR FEDERAL DOLLARS BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY TO VENT
MAXIMIZE ACCESS. TO THEM ON
SERVICES AND I KNOW THAT THE
FIREFIGHTERS BASICALLY WHEN
SOMEONE CALLS YOU HAVE TO SHOW
UP AND WHETHER DATE.
BUT THE YOU PAY NOTHING FOR VERY
LITTLE HER THE THE ONLY SO -- WE
NEED TO BE SURE WE SUPPORT THAT
SERVICE EVERYONE EXPECTS IT --
AND SO I CAN WIN.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ABOUT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO MOVE I
CENTER STONE MOTIONS TO PASS
REFER TO THE COMMUNITY AT
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI AND I STONE STONE I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROW FURTADO.
HER TITLE I LABOR MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I MORNING RUBIO.
REVIEW BY.
HEY THAT FELT EARLY AS SIX VOTES
THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET IT OUT TO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU TO CHAIR THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES AND THANK YOU
STAFF ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OKAY
NEXT UP I SEE IS A SIMILAR TANG
ITEM NUMBR SIX EIGHTY FIVE
TWELVE WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR HELP -- ON
A. B..
FIVE TWELVE AS YOU KNOW UNDER
EXISTING LAW UNDER THE FEDERAL
PATIENT PROTECTION FOR CHARACTER.
CARS NEARLY ALL HEALTH PLANS TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH CARE FOR
THEIR MEMBERS ALTHOUGH THERE'S
BEEN TREMENDOUS GAINS AND ACCESS
TO CARE.
CAN USE OF COLOR ANOTHER BARGE
LIES COMMUTES OFTEN EXPERIENCE
SUBOPTIMAL OUTCOMES WHEN IT
COMES TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE
TREATMENT.
THIS BILL EXPENSE INFORMATION
COLLECTED REPORTED UTILIZE IN
CULTURAL COMPETENCY PLANS FOR
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS.
IN ADDITION IT CREATES A LOCAL
COUNTY COMMITTEE FOR COMMUNITIES
TO ENGAGING GIVE THEIR INPUT ON
HOW TO IMPROVE ACCESS -- BY
COLLECTING INFORMATION ABOUT
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS
UTILIZATION AND OUTCOMES BY RACE
ETHNICITY LANGUAGE DISABILITY
STATUS SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
GENDER IDENTITY IN RACIAL STATUS
WE WILL MOVE MORE TOWARD HIM WE
WILL MOVE TOWARDS MORE
RESPONSIVE AND EFFECTIVE
CULTURAL COMPETENCY PLANTS.
WITHOUT RESPECT FOR YES FOR A
VOTE AND WE HAVE. TWO WITNESSES.
OKAY WELCOME THESE BEGIN.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR PAM
OTHER DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM YES ON
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF ONE
CULTURE CENTER BUTTE COUNTY H.
CCBC.
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TOLD
THE CULTURAL COMPETENCE IN
MENTAL HEALTH -- ET CBC HAS
PARTICIPATED IN THE COUNTY'S
CULTURAL COMPETENCY COMMITTEE
FOR MANY YEARS -- TO INCREASE
CULTURALLY RELEVANT MATTEL
SERVICES THROUGH A DATA
COLLECTION FOCUS GROUPS AND
SURVEYS UNFORTUNATELY THESE
ENGAGEMENTS HAVE YET TO CREATE
CONCRETE STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS.
AS A MENTAL HEALTH FOR THEM MAUN
COMMUNITY DUE TO LACK OF
OVERSIGHT OF CULTURE COMPTON'S
COMMITTEE -- HAS REGARDING THE
COUNTY OF THE COUNTRY'S CULTURE
CONTENTS PLAN -- INSIDE I THINK
WHAT WHAT HAPPENED -- TO OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO REMAIN
UNDIAGNOSED UNTREATED AND
ENDANGERING THEIR LIVES ON THE
LIVING WITH PTSD OR ANXIETY
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT TO HEALTH SERVICES --
SO EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE IMPROVES A
CULTURE COMPETENCY OF COUNTY
MENTAL PLANS -- MAKING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES MORE ACCESSIBLE
FOR THEM ON COMMUNITY -- TO
ACCESS -- LIFESAVING CARE AND
FINALLY HELPED AND THE WORD THAT
THERE -- WE LIVE EVERY DAY I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON
THIS IMPORTANT.
ISSUE AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF ALL CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND IRISH YOUR SUPPORT
ON A. B. FIVE OFF.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HAVING ME TODAY.
MY NAME IS RYAN TO IN THE
COUNSELING PROGRAM MANAGER AT
THE GENERAL SENSORS LOCATED
RIGHT HERE IN MY TOWN SECOND I
KNOW.
WHERE TRANS LED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT PRIMARILY
SERVES NEEDS OF TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY MEMBERS?
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
COUNSELING PROGRAM ACTUALLY TO
SEE IS -- OPERATOR COUNSELING
SERVICES BUT WE ALSO.
MICHAEL THREE CONCENTRATING FOR
MASTERS AND POST GRADUATE LEVEL
CLINICIANS -- AND YOU KNOW
ALTHOUGH THE FRAMERS IN THE
SPIRIT OF CULTURAL COMPETENCE
HAS LONG BEEN.
LONG EXISTED IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH FIELD THE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
INSUFFICIENT DATA AND PREVENT
TRACKING HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
DISPARITIES IN QUALITY AND
ACCESS. TWO MINUTE HOLD
TREATMENT FOR LGBTQ COMMUNITIES
THAN FOR TRANSGENDER COMMUNITIES.
OF COLOR IN PARTICULAR WE KNOW
THAT THE LACK OF CULTURALLY
COMPETENT.
MENTAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES
DRAMATIZES AND EVENTUALLY
DISCOURAGES US.
FROM SEEKING SERVICES IN THE
FIRST PLACE -- AND EVEN THOUGH
THESE COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES -- NEARLY A QUARTER
OF TRANSGENDER ADULTS REPORT
THAT DEVOID IS SEEKING MENTAL
HEALTH OR HEALTH CARE -- DUE TO
THE FEAR OF BEING MISTREATED.
AS A TRANSGENDER PERSON AN OUT
OF THE ADULTS THAT DID SEE A
PROVIDER.
A THIRD OF THEM REPORTED HAVING
A NEGATIVE EXPERIENCE -- RELATED
TO BEING TRANSGENDER WHETHER --
IS RELATED TO YOUR BEING REFUSED
TREATMENTS OR BEING HARASSED AT
THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE.
AND WE HEAR THE STORIES
CONSTANTLY AT THE GENERAL
CENTERS SPECIALLY FROM.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO TRAVEL --
THREE TO FIVE FROM THREE FIVE
HOURS AWAY TO RECEIVE OUR
SERVICES.
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
CULTURE CLUB THE CARE BY
INCORPORATING FEEDBACK IN ACTION
AS PART OF A ROUTINE MEDICAL
SERVICE -- AT THE END OF EVERY
COUNSELING SESSION WE COLLECT
FEEDBACK TO EVALUATE TRACKED THE
QUALITY.
OF THE THERAPEUTIC RELATIONSHIP --
AND WE ALSO ARE PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT THE VALUE IT'S THE THE
CULTURAL COMPETENCE OF OUR
MINIMAL PROGRAMMING.
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO REDUCE MY
HEALTH DISPARITIES WITHIN THIS
COMMUNITY. EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE IT
SET PERFORMANCE GOALS RIGHT
GREATER GUIDANCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ENSURE.
THAT COUNTIES RECEIVE AN IMPLANT
THE SAME KIND OF FEEDBACK.
NEEDED TO SUCCESSFULLY MEET THE
DIVERSE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AT
LEAST PLEASE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A LINDA TERROR WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PENNANT THINK HEALTH
NETWORK PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT OTHER
WITNESSES SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ADRIAN CHILTON WITH THE
STEINBERG ANSWER TO PROD CO
SPONSOR.
THANK YOU -- CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT YOU.
TIFFANY TRAVEL THE SOUTHEAST
ASIA RESOURCE ACTIONS THAT ARE
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE HAVING OUR
SAY COALITION AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH EQUITY COLLABORATIVE IS
DRUGS FOUR OF EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE
THANK YOU.
ABBY ARREARS ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HELP THE
CALIFORNIA AND AND GUY PRATT CO
SPONSORS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SPORT
THANK YOU.
AMANDA LEVY THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESIDENCE HALLS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. TWENTY
DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION MOVING TO A FULL
SUPPORT WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AMANDA MCALLISTER WONDER WITHOUT
FOR MENTAL HELTH IN THE
CALIFORNIA AT ALL TO BE TWO Q.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
NETWORK PRIDE CUTS COSPONSORED
SPORT.
THANK YOU.
BRIAN SALE ON BEHALF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVER SAID KHAN
BUILDING COMMISSION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
G. A. WITH THE MOTORS AND A FEW
CUNNING AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
THE WITNESS IS IN OPPOSITION.
SAY NONE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- CENTER
GONZALEZ.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO%
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY -- WHO FLED THE COME I
ROUGE -- THAT MENTAL HEALTH NEED
IS SO.
GREAT AND THIS IS SUCH A LOW
COST FOR SUCH A MAJOR IMPACT --
IN OUR COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND SINCE EVERYONE IS
ASKING TO CO SPONSOR CO AUTHOR I
WOULD LOVE TO DO THAT.
IF THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
HAPPY TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS.
IT CENTERS ON A I WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH AND
WOULD ALSO LOVE TO BE PART OF
THAT THIS BILL YOUR BILL.
AS A CO AUTHOR.
BRITTANY THINKING YEAH
ABSOLUTELY.
WITH ALL THE CO AUTHOR REQUESTS
FOR THE MOTION.
ALL RIGHTS IN DEVICES -- TANTO
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU. SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THE MENTAL HEALTH THE
RATE CHALLENGING ENOUGH WITH THE
STIGMA THAT'S ATTACHED
UNFORTUNATELY -- THAT -- STILL --
ATTACHED IN BOTH OUR MAINSTREAM
CULTURE AND ALSO MANY OTHER
CULTURES AND SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT BEYOND IN
ADDITION TO THAT THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING THE CULTURAL ISSUES
THAT ARE SURROUNDING THAT THE
THAT THE YOUR BILL DRESSES SO I
THINK SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE AGAIN I
THINK YOU.
I COULDN'T WELL AND JUST ALL THE
SENATORS OCCUR OCCUR WELL BUT
JUST RESPECT FOR US RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU SO IT'S BEEN SECONDED
BY CENTER TYLER THE MOTIONS TO
PASS REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YEAH HI CAN I STONE STONE NOW
CAN DOLLARS DOLLARS I'D GROW
FURTADO. FOR TITLE I AM LEBEN
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I MORNING RUBIO.
REVEALED BY.
I'VE WON A TRUCKLOAD IS FIVE ONE
THAT'S ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT
THE WHOLE THE ROLE OF THE TRAPS
IN NUMBERS THANK YOU RIGHT.
I SEE SEPTEMBER ECKMAN.
WELCOME -- SO WE HAVE ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IS
MY HONOR TO BE HERE BEFORE YOU
TODAY -- AMBER TO CONTINUE
TALKING ABOUT MEDICARE AL AND
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH -- SO
THIS BILL FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN IS
A WHICH THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL -- AND I'LL SAY
THIS BILL WAS BIGGER BUT BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THE FANTASTIC WORK BY
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE WERE ABLE
TO GET SOME OF THE THINGS TAKEN
CARE OF TO WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THIS PART OF THE BILL.
SO THIS IS FOR A WOMAN WHO IS
GIVEN BIRTH SHE'S ON MEDICARE
ALL SHE GOES IN AND OTHERS WELL
BABY CHECK UP SHE'S GOT A MENTAL
HEALTH DIAGNOSES NOW.
THIS IS THAT YOU SHOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE CONTINUITY OF CARE WITH
THAT SERVICE PROVIDER FOR UP TO
A YEAR AFTER THAT WE KNOW THAT
HEALTHY MOMS MAKE HEALTHY BABIES
MAKE HEALTHY COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS A SIMPLE LITTLE BUILD IT
PROVIDES CONTINUITY OF CARE --
FOR WOMEN MOST AT RISK WHO HAVE
SOME MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A COPY OF CARE WITH
THEIR PROVIDER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I WROTE AND I HAVE --
RAIN HERE.
RIGHT RIGHT.
RIGHT RIGHT FRIENDS HERE ALL
RIGHT ACTUALLY BEFORE WE BEGIN
WITH A WITNESS TO SUPPORT --
SEVERAL ADMIN I THINK WE DID
HAVE SOME SEASON UP THAT TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT.
THANKS VERY MUCH RIGHT.
WELCOME WITH THE SUPPORT.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRYCHNINE WHERE THE SPONSORS OF
THE MEASURE.
IT'S LONG BEEN A PRIORITY OF A
CLOCK TO ENSURE THAT WOMEN WHO
ARE DIAGNOSED WITH MEN COLONEL
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS WE SEE
THAT CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THE
APPROPRIATE COURSE OF TREATMENT --
THE CON YOU CARE PROVISIONS IN
AB FIVE SEVEN SEVEN GOES A LONG
WAY IN MAKING SURE THAT HAPPENS
SO WE ALONG WITH THE COVERING
CAT MAKE THEM A PHYSICIAN'S
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. TWO OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
BACK MY FRIEND.
YEAH SENATOR SOMETIMES THE MARCH
OF DIMES AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THEN ASK HIM -- KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HONEY DELGADO WITH CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JANICE ROCK ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REALLY BE MY BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS IN THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MORE SECONDS ALSO ME HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
YOU.
STEPHANIE IS A WITH THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AMELIA BOCHY SEE SANTA CRUZ
STUDENT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU --
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AMANDA LEVY CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAME NUMBER YOU BACK TO
COMMITTEE -- QUESTIONS COMMENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MOTIONS.
THERE'S A MOTION.
POSTER MITCHELL DID MOVE US
SAYING NO THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CAN -- IS AN AMERICAN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
ON THE MEND IT WHICH REALLY WAS
JUST TO LINE IT UP MORE WITH THE
PREGNANCY VERSES SO THAT WE
MAINTAIN THE CONTINUITY OF SIDE.
SO REPRIEVE SHEET THAT -- WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE BY JUST THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND FIRE UP RAIN SPENCER.
AFTER ALL THE WORK THAT HE'S
DONE ON THIS AS WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY THANK YOU SO IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR MITCHELL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HI CAN I STONE.
STONE I AND CONSOLIDATES CONSOLE
AS I GROW FURTADO FURTADO I
LABOR MITCHELL.
SO I MORNING RUBIO.
REVIEW I THINK THAT BILL CURLY
AS SIX VOTES -- WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
LET'S GET OUT THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WHILE WE'RE WAITING.
FOR THE FOR MEMBERS TO SHOW UP
WE DO HAVE -- COUPLE BUILD YOU
TOOK UP AND SUB COMMITTEE AND SO
OF A SOME MEMBER WOULD SO WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO EIGHTY TWO OH FOR MY SUMMER
WOULD DISOWN HOSPITALS COULD BE
BENEFIT PLAN REPORTING IS THERE
A MOTION ON THIS BILL.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
STONE -- IT'S AGAIN ITEM NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY TWO OH FOUR BY SOME
MEMBER WOULD THAT'S ON THAT
COMMITTEE BENEFITS REPORTED PLAN
REPORTING BY HOSPITALS.
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OUT ON DATES MOVED THE
MOTIONS TO PASS REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SACRED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CAN
I I STONE STONE I CAN SOLID.
CONTROLLERS PSYCH ROSE HER TADO
FOR TITLE I LABOR MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I MINING RUBIO.
REVIEW BY THAT BILL CURRY A SIX
FOOT SIX ZERO OF A HOLD THE ROLE
OF CONTRAPTION MEMBERS AND THEN
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY SIXTEEN FORTY TWO BY SOME
MEMBER WOULD -- IT'S ON MEDIC
COW MANAGED CARE PLANS IS THERE
A MOTION ON THE BILL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SIR TADA
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLAND AT
THE MOTIONS DO PASSES AMENDED
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CAN.
I STONE STONE NO SOLACE.
GONZALEZ I GROW HER TACO. FOR
TOTO I LABOR [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
HI MITCHELL I MORNING RUBIO.
HI OKAY RUBIO I AT THAT BILL
CURRENTLY IS FIVE ONE THAT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
STILL IN OKAY -- WEEK --
ACTUALLY READ SO YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT I'M GOING TO CLOSE GO ROLL
DOWN THE ROLE THAT ROLE FOR
BILL'S RETURN SEE FAT FOR I HAD
A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT ON SO LET'S
MOVE BACK TO ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
665% -- BERG SIXTY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS LLEVA
MINING RUBIO REVEALED BY THAT
BUT IT'S CURRENTLY.
SIX ZERO EVERYONE ELSE HERE FOR
EVERYTHING ELSE ARE DOING -- WE
JUST DID.
SELL SEE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE ANYONE IS.
NOW EVERYONE'S BEEN HERE FOR
FIVE OKAY [inaudible] SIX ONE
ZERO SIX IT'S BEEN HERE. FOR SIX
SEVEN WHICH IS IS. ZERO NOT
EVERYONE HERE FOR NINE DAYS.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY ONE BY SEVERAL GRAYSON ON
AIR AMBULANCE SERVICES THE
MOTION WAS TO PASS REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS ROW.
LAVER MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I MORNING RUBIO.
RUBIO I PAY THAT VOTE IS
CURRENTLY [inaudible]
SIX ZERO IN CHINA --
SO JUST FOR
ALL THE PEOPLE WATCHING ON T. --
WE ARE WAITING FOR MEMBERS TO
PRESENT -- FOLLOWING MEMBERS
STILL HAVE BILLS BEFORE THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WE HAVE SOME
MEMBER BURKE -- SOME REMEMBER --
WHEN SIMILARLY MON SOME MEMBER
IGOR CURRY?
SEPTEMBER CORREO SUMMER JONES
SWEAR AND DECEMBER DAILY HAVE
BILLS THAT ARE ON OUR AGENDA
WHICH WE HAVE NOT HEARD YET
[inaudible]
YEAH -- THE WAY
HE FOR AUTHORS
BUT I SEE -- VS ARE ROLLING DOWN
SO YOU CAN ADD ON TO ALL THE
BILLS IF YOU WISH.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA OPEN
THE ROLLS ON FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
AS WERE WAY FOR AUTHORS THIS IS
AN AUTHOR SHOWS UP WE WILL BE WE
WILL HEAR YOUR BILLS.
OKAY SO WE'LL GO BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE ACTUALLY DID YOU VOTE.
ALL RIGHT SO -- THE OKAY -- SO
WE'LL START -- THE ROLAND ITEM
NUMBER ONE SP SIX SIXTY FIVE A
SENATOR UMBERG CLASSIC THREE THE
MOTIONS TO PASS REFER TO
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS GROVE.
FLAVOR MORNING MORNING I CHECK.
THE OF THE CURRENT VOTE IS NOW.
787- AND WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN.
ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY TWO OH
FOUR BY DECEMBER THE WOOD -- THE
MOTIONS TO PASS REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE LLEVA.
MORNING MORNING HI HEY THE THAT
BODES CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO AND
WE'LL KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN -- THE
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR ONE FOUR BY SOME
MEMBER BONTA TICKET PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT SOME MEMBERS ROVE
LIVE A MINING.
MINING I OKAY NEXUS -- OKAY SO
THAT NOW CURRENTLY SIX ONE WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEMS I AND NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE BY SOME
MEMBERS TAKING SIXTY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS.
ROVE LAVER MINING.
MORNING I SUCCESS OF THAT
CURRENTLY IS SIX ONE WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
NEXT ITEMS I AND NUMBER EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN FOR BY
SOME NUMBER EIGHT MEN. SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS GROW FLAVOR MOANING.
THAT IS THE MANDATE AS AMENDED
DST PASSES A MEDFORD ACADIAN
PREPARATIONS CHAIR SUPPORT YES
[inaudible]
MORNING I THAT BILLS CURRENTLY
SEVEN ZERO KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY ONE BY SOME MEMBER GRAYSON.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ROW LABOR MINING.
MINING I SEVEN THAT IS CURRENTLY
SEVEN ZERO KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHTY TWELVE
FORTY NINE BY SUMMER REMAND
SHINE.
SEPARATE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THAT SOME MEMBERS.
GROWTH LEVIN MINING.
HAD THE CHAIRS I MORNING I
SECOND.
THAT IS THE CURRENT LOTUS SEVEN
ZERO KEEP THE ROLE FOR OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY BY SOME
MEMBER BONTA SIX OR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS ROW
FLAVOR MINING.
MORNING I SEVEN ZERO OKAY THAT
FITS CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY SIXTEEN FORTY TWO BY
SOME MEMBER WOULD SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS ROVE LABOR MORNING.
MORNING NINE SIX ONE EIGHT
THAT'S THE CURRENT LEASE.
ROLL SIX ONE WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
FAMILY OF ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SEVENTEEN OH FIVE BY
SUMMER PONTA SECURITIES CALLED
ROLLED UP TO MEMBERS ROW FLAVOR
MINING.
MINING I SEVEN ZERO EIGHT THAT
THAT'S CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO KEEP
THE ROLL UP IN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
OKAY WHICH IS.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU FIRST.
I WOULD SAY I'LL WAIT TILL THE
END FOR THAT.
OKAY WE ARE STILL WAITING
[inaudible]
FOR MEMBERS
.
SO AGAIN FOR A THEY'RE WAITING.
FOR IS THERE A SEVEN MEMBER.
FOR SEVERAL -- WHEN SEVERAL WELL
KNOWN CENTER AGARIC CURRY?
SUMMER TRIO SUMMER JOHN SAWYER
ARE SEMI RICKETS DAILY.
WITH.
THEIR URBAN WELL COME.
PLEASE COME ON UP WE ARE READY
FOR YOU ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO WELCOME.
GOSH I'M SURE YOU'RE SO HAPPY TO
SEE SOMEBODY HERE SO YOU CAN GET
THIS OVER WITH -- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH HAVE
BEEN HANDED OUT -- AB ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO AUTHORIZES THE COUNTY
OF INTEREST TO CONDUCT A PILOT
PROJECT TO PREDICT.
WHICH MEDICARE RECIPIENTS ARE
LIKELY TO BECOME SUPER USERS AT
THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
AND RHODE ISLAND A SIMILAR
PROJECT WAS ABLE TO IDENTIFY
THESE INDIVIDUALS WITH 8290%
ACCURACY.
AND WAS ABLE TO REDUCE COSTS BY
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IF THIS PREDICTIVE MODELING CAN
BE REPLICATED IN VENTURA COUNTY
IT CAN BE SHARED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY AND WITH
ME TODAY IS KIM STONE WITH
GOVERNOR FOR CALIFORNIA TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
KIM STONE ON BEHALF OF GOVERNOR
FOR CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AT THE COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK IN LEADERSHIP ON THAT THAT
THIS BILL.
MOST OF THE TIME YOU ALL AS
LEGISLATORS OFTEN HAVE TO DECIDE
BETWEEN -- SPENDING MONEY TO
HELP PEOPLE OR SAVING MONEY AND
THEN NOT HELPING PEOPLE BUT IF
THIS PILOT PROJECT PROVES
AFFECTED YOU WILL BOTH SAVE
MONEY AND HELP PEOPLE -- I I'M.
I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT IT.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
BUT BACK FROM [inaudible]
YOUR PART.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SAY NONE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SCISSOR MOTION
THAT'S BEEN MOVED BY A CENTER
CONSOLIDATES -- SO S. AS IN --
WE'RE GONNA I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE --
REALLY -- EXCITED ABOUT THIS
IDEA OF THE SUPER USER PROJECT
WE DID SOMETHING SIMILAR AT E.
R. USE IN SACRAMENTO WE I'VE.
AND IT YEAH WE KNOW THAT --
ACTUALLY THE THE ICON CALLED SIX
BUT THE 5% THAT USE THE MOST
SERVICES ACTUALLY USE OVER 50%
THE DOLLAR IF YOU START THINKING
ABOUT THE ONES AT THE VERY END
IF WE CAN DO MUCH BETTER TRYING
TO FOCUS ON THEM WE CAN ACTUALLY.
HAVE SIGNIFICANT COST REDUCTION
AND SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR THE FOR THESE FOLKS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WELL I
JUST I JUST WANT TO SAY SO THIS
WAS A THIS IS A PROFESSOR AT
BROWN UNIVERSITY WHO USES DATA
POOLS TO IT TO SOLVE A LOT OF
SOCIETAL PROBLEMS AND THE GREAT
THING ABOUT VENTURA COUNTY IS
IT'S ABOUT THE SAME SIZE AS
RHODE.
ISLAND SO WE'RE REALLY
INTERESTED IN SEEING IF THIS
WORKS FOR THE COUNTY AND THEN WE
CAN ADOPT TO THE STATE AND AND
THE WE'LL BE ABLE TO DO THIS
THROUGH THIS PILOT PROGRAM.
OKAY THANK YOU SO IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY -- CENTER GONZALEZ THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AMENDED REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAM HI CAN I STONE STONE I
GONZALES GONZALES I'D GROVE HER
TADO.
LABOR MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I MINING RUBIO. FOR A
THE BILL CURLY AS FOUR VOTES --
FOR WILL CALL THE ROLL OF
CONTRACTS AND NUMBERS THANK YOU
AND GOOD TO KNOW THAT MEANS
OFTEN REPRESENT.
OUR DISTRICTS ARE LARGER MANY
STATES.
ALL RIGHT -- I SEE THAT'S I
THINK MAKES WORK WOULD BE A
SEVER ACCURATE CURRY WELCOME
OKAY SO IT'S ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR HOW COME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
FIRST I WILL BE TAKING THE
COMMITTEE'S CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FOUR IS FOLLOW UP LEADS TO
LEGISLATION THAT I AUTHORED LAST
YEAR.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
TIMELY ACCESS CARE WHEN DISASTER
STRIKES. FOR EXAMPLE.
DURING THE TUBS FIRE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE SANTA
ROSA COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE
CENTER.
PROVIDERS MADE FOURTEEN HUNDRED
TWELVE TELEPHONIC VISITS TO
THEIR PATIENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CENTER HE IS
YET TO BE REIMBURSED FOR THE
CARE PROVIDED AND THERE'S NO
GUIDANCE ON HOW CLAIMS AND
RECORD SHOULD BE SUBMITTED. TO
THE STATE DURING EMERGENCIES
WHEN CLINICS ARE INACCESSIBLE
DAMAGED OR DESTROYED.
AB FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR
CLARIFIES THE SERVICES PERFORM
OUTSIDE THE CLINICS FOR WALLS
DUE TO AN EMERGENCY SITUATION
MUST BE REIMBURSABLE WHETHER IN
A SHELTER.
A PATIENT'S HOME BY PHONE OR
THROUGH TELEHEALTH.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO DEVELOP.
GUIDANCE TO THIS ISSUE SO THAT
THE STANDARDS AND EXPECTATIONS
FOR REIMBURSEMENT OF SERVICES
PROVIDED DURING AN EMERGENCY ARE
CLEAR.
SENATORS I ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
GET THE SUPPORT WELCOME.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
THE AFFILIATE OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS THE OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
AND CLINICS IN CALIFORNIA -- AS
THE AUTHOR STATED WE DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE FIRE IN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE HAD ABOUT TWO DOZEN
HEALTH CENTER CORPORATION
SERVING A TEN COUNTY REGION
WHICH SERVE ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND PATIENTS IMPACTED BY
THE FIRES -- MOST NOTABLY -- OF
EXAMPLE WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS THE
CENTER IS A COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER WHICH LOST -- COMPLETELY
THEIR LARGEST CAMPUS THAT SERVE
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND PATIENTS SO
THEY WERE REALLY TRYING TO REACH-OUR PATIENTS HE ATTACK -- THE
TELEPHONE TRYING TO LOCATE THEM
WHERE THEY WERE EITHER IN AN
EVACUATION SHELTER OR OUTSIDE OF
THE REGION -- FOLLOW UP WITH THE
PATIENTS WHO HAD JUST BEEN
PRESCRIBED PERHAPS MENTAL HEALTH
MEDICATIONS MAKE SURE THEY
WEREN'T HAVING ANY SORT OF SIDE
EFFECTS FOLLOW UP WITH THEIR ADS --
PATIENTS WHO HAVE AS MUCH TO
MAKE SURE THEY WERE NOT --
ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY THE FIRES --
AND BECAUSE AS THE AUTHOR STATED
THE LIMITATIONS AROUND HOW A
COMMUNITY CLINIC CAN BE
REIMBURSED IF THAT OF THIS IT
DOES NOT HAPPEN WITH INSIDE THE
FOUR WALLS OF THE CLINIC THEY
CANNOT BE REIMBURSED SO.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THE DEPARTMENT --
TO PROVIDE CLARITY TO THE HEALTH
CENTERS ABOUT WHAT THE HOW THEY
CAN -- OPERATE DURING A DECLARED
STATE OF EMERGENCY WHEN THERE
ACTUALLY IS NO HEALTH CENTER --
SO WE WE FEEL LIKE THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY TO NOT ONLY ADDRESS
THE THE HEALTH CENTERS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN IMPACTED BUT TO
PROVIDE SOME CLARITY GOING ON A
GOING FORWARD BASIS -- FOR
HEALTH CENTER SO THEY KNOW HOW
TO OPERATE AND BE ABLE TO BE
REIMBURSED FOR THE SERVICES THEY
PROVIDE SO WANT TO THANK YOU IN
OUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US AND WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU I THINK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO BE HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING CITY AND COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE HERE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNIFER ALLEY WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT SENCER PERHAPS THE
CALIFORNIA PODI AFTER MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND SPORT THANK YOU.
BRANDON MARCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OKAY BILLS INTO THAT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OKAY SAYING NONE OF THE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED HAS BEEN
MOVED -- THANK YOU SENATOR CURRY
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
CLEARLY DURING A DISASTER --
PEOPLE'S AS CLEAN THEIR USUAL
MEDICAL CARE NEEDS DON'T GO AWAY
EITHER AND THERE MAY BE NEW ONES
IT'S IMPORTANT PEOPLE OF ACCESS
TO CARE.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I SIMPLY
AFTER I VOTE FOR THE ALL THE
DOCTORS AND PATIENTS SO THAT.
WERE LEFT HIGH AND DRY DURING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SO THIS BILL'S BEEN MOVED
BY BOTH CENTER STONES HER
MITCHELL.
EMOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH OUR COMMITTEE STAFF THE
PASSES AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HAND BY HAND I STONE STONE
AIKENS ALWAYS CONTROL ASIDE GROW
FURTADO LABOR MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M RUNNING RUBIO.
HEY CURRENTLY THE VOTERS FOUR
ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF THE
DRAFT MEMBERS SAY THANK YOU AND
HAVE A GOOD AFTERNOON OKAY THANK
YOU I SEE SOME EVER DAILY HERE.
SINCE YOUR LAST YEAR GET UP HERE
BEFORE SOMEONE ELSE AS A
FOLLOWER.
OKAY I'M NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY NINE WELCOME
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO ADOPT
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR RECOVERY
RESIDENCES.
THAT RECEIVES STATE FUNDING.
BY ESTABLISHING A BASELINE FOR
QUALITY.
CALIFORNIA WILL TAKE THE FIRST
STEP TOWARD IDENTIFYING
RESIDENCES THAT ARE SAFE FOR
BOTH PEOPLE IN RECOVERY.
AND THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH
THEY ARE LOCATED.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE TO STRENGTHEN SEVERAL
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
I AM ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS --
WHICH WERE A PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND I'M JOINED BY SHERRY DAILY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM
OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN BURST -- THIS BILL IS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS -- FIRST OFF IT KEEPS
THE BAD APPLES WHO ARE REVOKED
AS TREATMENT PROVIDERS SO THOSE
WHO ARE PROVIDING INPATIENT
TREATMENT.
SOMETIMES A REVOKED FOR HARMING --
CLIENTS OR FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY --
THE BILL CONTAINS A PROVISION
THAT WOULD PREVENT THEM FROM
THEN RECREATING THEMSELVES AS A
RECOVERY RESIDENTS IN ENTERING
THE PAYMENT SYSTEM THE THROUGH
THE BACK DOOR TO RECOVERY
RESIDENTS FUNDING TO THE
COUNTIES -- IT SETS A STATE
STANDARD SO THAT IN ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES WHO WILL NOW BE
ABLE TO CONTRACT WITH THEIR
SAPPY BLOCK FUNDING FOR THESE
SERVICES WOULD HAVE A MINIMUM
STANDARD.
AND IT WILL SAVE LIVES BECAUSE
IT REQUIRES THE NORTH PHILLY IT
SAYS THE NATIONAL SOLUTION OF
ASSOCIATION OF RECOVERY
RESIDENCES TO REQUIRE WHEN THEY
GO OUT AND INSPECT THE HOME. TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR CAN THE
LIFESAVING ANTI REVERSAL
MEDICATION PROPIO OVERDOSE IS ON
HAND AND AVAILABLE TO USE.
I THANK THE CHAIR HIS STAFF ARE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF AND OUR
FRIENDS A CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS FOR CRAFTING A PIECE OF
COMPROMISE LEGISLATION.
THAT RESPECTS THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
OF THE INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN
HOMES WHILE IMPROVING THE
QUALITY FOR THEM I WOULD -- TRY
THAT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
MAY YOUR MOTION FROM CENTER
STONE.
HONEY DELGADO WITH THE KIND OF
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS WE MOVED TO A FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR KERR CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE BEEN OPPOSED -- BUT WITH
THE AMENDMENTS NOW WE'VE MOVED
TO A TWEENER WE STILL HAVE ONE
LITTLE CONCERN THAT I THINK
WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO WORK OUT WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
MAKING THE STANDARDS ADOPTING
THE STANDARDS ESSENTIALLY OF A
PRIVATE REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT
TO ADOPT STANDARDS OF A PRIVATE --
INTO THE AND IF WE CAN GET TO
THE POINT THAT IT'S SENSUALLY
ALLOW -- THE DEPARTMENT -- TO
PICK AND CHOOSE AFTER
CONSULTATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS I
THINK WE'LL GET THERE AND WE'D
BE SUPPORT WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR -- FOR IN THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE
ON THE BILL AND HELPING US GET
THERE THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
YES MCAFEE MANTA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES WE HAVE BEEN OPPOSED.
AND WE HAVE TO REVIEW THESE
AMENDMENTS AND AND TAPPED HIM
AND SEE WHERE WE COME OUT THANK
YOU.
RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- US AS A WITNESS IS
AN OPPOSITION THAT THINK WE JUST
TURNED UP AS AS ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
OKAY SCENE NINE IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER SON ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT SO AGAIN AS OF TODAY
THEY WANT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE --
AND ALSO WORKING WITH THE SOME
OF THE STAKE HOLDERS AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK --
WILL CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE BILL
WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
IT'S A CHALLENGING SUBJECT BUT I
THINK WE'VE MADE GOOD PROGRESS I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFS WORK AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THAT REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS A SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HANDS HI CAN I STONE.
STONE I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW
HER TADO LABOR MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I MORNING RUBIO
[inaudible] FOR RIGHT THE
CURRENT LOTUS FOUR ZERO THE BILL
AND WE'LL PUT THE BILL A CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
RIGHT [inaudible]
HEY.
SO WE ARE STILL WE ARE WAITING
FOR AUTHORS -- AND I'D SO
CURRENTLY WE STILL HAVE -- A
SEVEN MEMBER BURKE.
DECEMBER TRIO.
AND CENTERED JONES SAWYER AND WE
ACTUALLY WON NOW I RECOGNIZE
THAT WE HAD A VISIT FROM THE
CENTER CONSOLE AS WE SHOULD HAVE
A BILL HERE WITH US SO
[inaudible]
BUT
A PAST THE GAVEL ON TO
CENTER STONE HAS I HAVE TO RUN
DOWN TO SENATE EDUCATION
[inaudible]
PROBLEM [inaudible]
THANKS.
SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO WAIT FOR
AUTHORS [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE FIRST LETTER
[inaudible]
SENATOR A HOLLY MITCHELL I THINK
I HEARD YOU SAY YOU WANT TO MOVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
INDEED I DID I THOUGHT YOU.
I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR WONDERFUL
PROACTIVE AND I AM HERE I TRY
HARD SENATOR.
I KNOW YOU DO AND I APPRECIATE
YOU.
WHAT WHAT WHAT WILL TAKE A ROLE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR?
HAND STONED I STONE I'D
CONSOLIDATES GONZALEZ I'D GROWN
FURTADO LABOR MITCHELL HI.
HI MINING RUBIO.
UNANIMOUS.
BUT LEAVE IT OPEN ONLY WITH OPEN.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU TO THE AUDIENCE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE TO BE HERE TODAY
WE APPRECIATE IT [inaudible]
HELLO.
WHEN MY CURVES THANK?
YOU AT THE START
ASSEMBLYWOMAN
CORREO WE SEE YOU PLEASE STEP UP
TO THE PODIUM.
AND WE'D LIKE TO HEAR YOUR A. B.
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE AND WE
WELCOME YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF AND MEMBER.
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT A SIMILAR
BILL SIXTEEN AT NINETY FIVE
WHICH MAKES NECESSARY REFORMS TO
THE NURSING HOME INDUSTRY WHEN A
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP.
A CURSE TO ADDRESS ISSUES WITH
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO ENSURE
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS AS WELL AS
EMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS FOR
WORKERS DURING THIS PROCESS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN B
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE.
AND THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AT
THE REQUEST OF THE CHAIR I WOULD
LIKE TO I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE NEW PRE APPROVAL PROCESS
BY SIX MONTHS AND ALLOWING THE
INTERIM PROCESS TO MOVE FORWARD
IN THE DEPARTMENT IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
NOT MADE A DECISION.
IN NINETY DAYS THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE BEING PASSED OUT TO THE
MEMBERS NOW.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
LICENSING CERTIFYING AND
ENFORCING.
REGULATORY STANDARDS RELATED TO
THE QUALITY OF CARE PROVIDED IN
SKILLED NURSING HOME FACILITIES.
AND OTHER HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
DUE TO THE NUMBER OF FORMS AND
DOCUMENTS NEEDED TO OBTAIN A
LICENSE TO OPERATE A NURSING
HOME.
THE CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP APPROVAL
PROCESS MAY TAKE AT LEAST FOUR
MONTHS OR LONGER.
AB SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE WILL
ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES BY A ONE
REQUIRING THAT A LICENSEE NOTIFY
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ALL RESIDENTS.
NO LATER THAN NINETY DAYS PRIOR
TO THE SALE OR TRANSFER AND
REQUIRES A DEPARTMENT WITHIN
NINETY DAYS OF THIS NOTICE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE
PROSPECTIVE LICENSEES.
IS SUITABLE FOR LICENSURE OR IF
THEY'RE NOT.
SECOND.
BY PROHIBITING THE DEPARTMENT
FOR PROVIDING.
I'M SORRY PROHIBITING THE
DEPARTMENT FROM APPROVING A
TRANSFER OF OWNERSHIP OR
APPLICATION TO OPERATE A
FACILITY.
UNLESS THE PERSPECTIVE LICENSEE
HAS BEEN DETERMINED SUITABLE AND
LASTLY REQUIRING A SIXTY DAY
TRANSITION PERIOD OF STAFF TO
ALLOW FOR RESIDENTS TO
EXPERIENCE.
THE CONTINUITY OF CARE AND
PREVENTIVE THROW UP TO TURN OVER --
I WILL ALLOW THE THE WITNESS IS
HERE TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES FOR
FURTHER TESTIMONY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MY VOTE
THANK YOU SOME ROOMS YES YES SIX
MINUTES COLLECTIVELY WE WELCOME
YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CORREO FOR YOUR WORK
SPONSORING THIS BILL AND TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING US OUT TODAY.
MY NAME IS STATION LAMBERT I'M
REPRESENTING US YEAH YOU LOCAL
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND WE HAVE TWO
MEMBERS WITH US TO SHARE THEIR
STORIES AS WELL.
OUR INTEREST IN PASSING AB
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE DERIVED FROM
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACED AS
A UNION GUIDING AND SUPPORTING
OUR NURSING HOME MEMBERS WHEN.
NURSE WHEN NOT CHANGES IN
OWNERSHIP OCCUR WE'VE HEARD FROM
OUR MEMBERS VARIOUSLY AS THE
SITUATIONS OCCUR THAT THEIR
PAYCHECKS RELATE.
THAT PAYCHECKS THAT HAD BEEN
DISPERSED BY THE NEW EMPLOYER
THE OLD EMPLOYER WOULD BOUNCE OF
CASH THAT SUDDENLY NEW
MANAGEMENT STAFF FOR COMING IN
DIRECTING THEIR WORK THEY HAD NO
FOREWARNING THAT THESE CHANGES
IN OWNERSHIP WERE OCCURRING UP
UNTIL CHANGES IN THEIR SCHEDULE.
HEY ON BENEFITS WERE PASSED DOWN
WE'VE HAD DIFFICULTY FINDING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NEW
EMPLOYER WE WOULD CONTACT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND FIND
THAT THEY HADN'T BEEN NOTIFIED
TO RECEIVE THE FULL APPLICATION
YET.
AND NO PRIOR NOTICE UP TO THIS
POINT HAS BEEN REQUIRED FOR
OPERATIONAL -- MORE MANAGEMENT
OWNERSHIP CHANGES ARE HARD WON
CONTRACTS WOULD SUDDENLY BE
VOIDED WHICH OFFERS US LITTLE
RECOURSE FOR SETTLING GRIEVANCES
ARE NEGOTIATING WORKPLACE
STANDARDSWORKERS WHO'VE BEEN AT
FACILITIES FOR YEARS OR EVEN
DECADES ARE TOLD LAST MINUTE TO
REAPPLY FOR THEIR JOBS.
RESIDENCY SITE AND TURN OVER IN
THE DIRECT CARE STAFF SOME OF
WHOM THEY MAY HAVE KNOWN FOR
YEARS AND IN THE WORST CASES
FACILITIES GO YEARS WITHOUT THE
OFFICIAL OPERATOR BEING ON THE
BOOKS.
AND THEY HAVEN'T BEEN -- THEY
HAVEN'T UNDERGONE A VETTING
PROCESS THE THE THE LICENSING
PROCESS AND WHEN A PROBLEM
OCCURS -- SURVEYORS RESIDENTS
THEIR FAMILY MAN MEMBERS AND
OTHER ADVOCATES ARE UNCLEAR WHO
TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE AND THESE
ARE JUST A SAMPLE OF SOME OF THE
STORIES THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
OUR MEMBERS OVER THE YEARS.
AND SO AS A SOP TO SOME OF THE
MORE PERNICIOUS EFFECTS OF SIDE
AND COVERT OWNERSHIP CHANGES WE
PROPOSED A FEW IMPROVEMENTS TO
THIS PROCESS.
WOULD LIKE MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
NOTICE REGARDING WHO'S TAKING
OVER FACILITY BY IMPLEMENTING A
TIME LIMITED PRE APPROVAL
PROCESS IN TAKING CARE TO
CAPTURE SOME OF THE INTERIM --
MANAGEMENT ARRANGEMENTS ARE
OTHER THIRD PARTY MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENTS THAT WE'VE SEEN WE
ASK THAT THIS PROCESS -- TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT CRITICAL
INFORMATION ABOUT A PROSPECTIVE
OWNERS BUSINESS ORGANIZATION
BRETT B. TATIAN AND CAPABILITY
IN DELIVERING QUALITY CARE.
AND WE ASK THAT THERE BE A SIXTY
DAY RETENTION PERIOD TO ALLOW
FOR A SMOOTH TRANSITION AND
CONTINUITY OF CARE TO OFFER
WORKERS AND RESIDENTS TO PLAN
AHEAD AND ANTICIPATE SOME OF
THESE CHANGES -- SO WE WELCOME
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL
TODAY I'M AND I'M GOING TO TURN
IT OVER NOW TO OUR MEMBER CLOUDY
ACCOUNTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS SO THAT
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CLOUDY
COUNTS IN IRON MAN NERVE OF
RESTORATIVE NURSE ASSISTANT AT A
NURSING FACILITY LOCATED IN
PLASTER COUNTY.
AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF A SEE A
YEAR.
TWENTY FIFTEEN I'M HERE TODAY AS
A PERCENTAGE OF MY SISTERS AND
BROTHERS OF THE UNION TO SHINE A
LIGHT ON THERE REALLY PACKS OF
TRANSFER OF OWNERSHIP IN NURING
HOMES.
THE EXPERIENCE IS VERY MUCH LIKE --
WHEN SOMEONE PULLED THE RACK
FROM UNDER OUR FEET?
WAGES BENEFITS SCHEDULES.
A MAN IN OTHER THINGS ARE NO
LONGER -- GUARANTEED BY THE BY
AIR IS CONCERNED WITH KEEPING
THE COAST LOW.
AND DOES NOT SEE THE VALUE OF
NURSING HOME WORKERS IN
DELIVERING SAFE AND QUALITY CARE
FOR RESIDENTS -- GIVE ME I WISH
I COULD TELL YOU THAT THESE
THINGS HAPPEN RARELY BUT CHANGE
OF OWNERSHIP OCCURS RIGHT OUT
BUT REGARDLESS LEE -- REGULARLY
REGARDLESS OF THE SIZE OF THE
COMPANY.
JUST RECENTLY A MEDIUM SIZED
HELPER -- OPERATE OR EXPERIENCE
THE FINANCIAL TROUBLE DECIDED TO
TRANSFERRED THEIR OPERATIONS
DESPITE WHAT THE EMPLOYER CLAIM
THAT TRANSITION HAS BEEN
ANYTHING BUT OR BAR ORDERLY.
PAYROLL CHECKS BOUNCE IN NO CASH
FLOW FOR DAILY EXPENSES TO
PROPERLY CARE FOR RESIDENTS. FOR
THESE REASONS HI PLEASE URGE YOU
ON BEHALF OF NURSING HOME
WORKERS.
OUT LIKE NEED TO SUPPORT AV
SIXTY NINETY FIVE BECAUSE
RESIDENTS IN NURSING HOME
WORKERS WHO ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE BUSINESS
TRANSACTION SHOULD BE PROTECTED
IN THE SERVER STABILITY AND
SMOOTH TRANSITION WHEN A
TRANSFER OF OWNERSHIP OCCURS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SHEILA
MA'AM SIGN.
I AM A CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANT
AT THE NURSING HOME FACILITY
LOCATED IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS.
AND I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF SEIU.
TWENTY FIFTEEN I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
FAILING TO PROTECT BOTH
RESIDENTS OF NURSING HOME
WORKERS WHEN THE FACILITY IS
BEING SOLD TO ANOTHER OPERATOR.
BUT A MERE STROKE OF LUCK.
I HAVE EXPERIENCE THE TRANSFER
OF OWNERSHIP TWICE IN TWO YEARS
IN THE AME FACILITY.
THE FIRST ROUND OF SALE
TRANSACTION WE WERE ASSURED THAT
THERE WILL BE A SEAMLESS
TRANSITION.
WELL THAT SEAMLESS TRANSITION
DID NOT INCLUDE OUR BENEFITS.
THE BUYER DECIDED TO SEAR OUT
ARE EARNED SICK DAYS AMONG OTHER
CHANGES TWO YEARS LATER WE ARE
AGAIN UNDERGOING A TRANSFER OF
OPERATIONS DUE TO FINANCIAL
TROUBLES.
WE HEARD THE SAME PROMISE ONLY
THIS TIME IT IS WORSE.
PAYROLL CHECK BOUNCERS
INADEQUATE SUPPLY LIKE DIAPER
FOR OUR RESIDENTS AND LOW
STAFFING.
OUR TRANSFER OF OWNERSHIP STORY
IS STILL UNFOLDING DESPITE WHAT
THE EMPLOYER IS CLAIMING THAT
TRANSITION HAS BEEN ANYTHING BUT
ORDERLY. FOR THESE REASONS I
URGE YOU ON BEHALF OF NURSING
HOME WORKERS LIKE MEET THE SPORT
AB.
SIXTY NINETY FIVE BECAUSE
RESIDENTS OF NURSING HOME
WORKERS WHO ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE BASICS
TRANSACTION SHOULD BE PROTECTED
AND THE SERBS STABILITY AND
SMALL TRANSITION WHEN THE
TRANSFER OF OWNERSHIP STICKERS
THANK YOU THEY GIVE HER
TESTIMONY WHEN I'LL ASK OTHER
SUPPORTERS TO COME FORWARD
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
AND WITH THE SUPPORT OR CORY
BARKER BG BEHALF OF SEIU LOCAL
TWENTY FIFTEEN IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ELSA I. NINA.
UP STOCKTON ON NURSING AND REHAB
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ARTHUR LEVIN THIS AND
SUPPORT THE MEMBER TO IN THE BIG
TEN AS A I YOU'LL.
HAVE A RALLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MEANT THE BON LOS ON THE CNA AT
COURTYARD HEALTHCARE IN DAVIS
AND I'M IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS A HOLY COW WHAT
THAT IN ON C. N. A. N. I SUPPORT.
A BEATEN SIXTY NINETY FIVE THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS YVONNE CHANCHAL ENEMA.
OF NURSING HOME WORKER AND I
SUPPORT L. A. B. SIXTEEN NINETY
FIVE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HASSLES FIGURE WHAT
CATCHER ARMAND ON NURSING HOME
WORKERS I'M IS A YOU. TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND I SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARTY ACKERMAN SEIU
MEMBER AND I'VE SADDAM DIETARY
ASSISTANT AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL USER.
THANKS.
MY NAME IS MARGIE REVERSE I AM A
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANT -- AND
ALSO AS A C. R. U. TWENTY
FIFTEEN MEMBER IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROL REESE I
WORK AT SKYLINE HEALTH CARE
CENTER I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ABBY REEVE ON
BEHALF OF SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANKS.
HI MY NAME IS AS THE LEAD THE
RADIUS FROM FREMONT THE HOT SPOT
FREEMAN HAS GOOD SAID THAT.
I SUPPORT THESE AB SIXTY NINETY
FIVE I'VE BEEN WORKING FOR
THIRTY SIX YEARS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
I'M TOM.
I'M HOME WITH I'M A MEMBER OF A
IS IS HE ARE YOU NOT. TWENTY
FIFTEEN I SUPPORT THESE PILLS.
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON TEA OR ON BEHALF OF
THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION STATE
COUNCIL INSTRUCTS SUPPORT THANKS.
SIR FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU YOUR THERE'S A SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTY NINETY FIVE PLEASE
COME FORWARD IF NOT FULL OF BY
THE OPPOSITION.
PLEASE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
JENNIFER SIGN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
FACILITIES -- FIRST WOULD LIKE
TO START BY.
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR -- FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THE AMENDMENTS THAT SHE'S
OFFERING TODAY WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE MOVING.
OUR POSITION TO NEUTRAL --
REMOVING OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
I'M JUST LIKE TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS -- BASED ON THAT --
OPPOSITION REMOVAL A COUPLE
THINGS IS I I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THE COMMITTEE KNOWS AND THE
AUTHOR KNOWS HOW MUCH AND AND
SHE'S HEARD THIS FROM US THAT
HOW MUCH WE AGREE THAT -- THE
CURRENT LICENSING PROCESS AND
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP PROCESS FOR
OF FACILITIES THAT ARE UNDER --
THE JURISDICTION APARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH IS BROKEN --
CURRENTLY -- THE AVERAGE TIME IT
TAKES FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
APPROVE A LICENSURE APPLICATION
IS A YEAR AND FOUR MONTHS.
WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES PENDING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT RIGHT NOW SOME HAVE
BEEN WAITING FOR FOR YEARS -- IT
SHOULD NOT.
IT SHOULD NOT BE THAT WAY -- AND
THAT IS WHY WE HAVE A PROCESS
WHEREBY -- A NEW A NEW OWNER
NEEDS TO STEP IN BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A FACILITY THAT STRUGGLING
AND SO THEY START AS AN AN
INTERIM MANAGER.
AND THEN ENTER MANAGER THAN
DOESN'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MEDICAID FUNDS THAT COME THROUGH
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM THOSE ARE
STILL GOING TO THE PREVIOUS
OWNER.
SO THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE A DELAY
IN -- PAYCHECKS GOING OUT FUNDS
BEING AVAILABLE -- AND I WOULD
SAY ON TOP OF THAT YOU HAVE --
NURSING FACILITIES THAT ARE OVER
YOU KNOW ALMOST 70% FUNDED BY
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THERE FOR THEIR
FUNDED WELL ENOUGH TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES AND THE ADEQUATE --
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED -- SO WE
HAVE FROM THE BEGINNING BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TWO MAIN
ANIMAL ELEMENTS OF THE BILL
WHICH ALLOW FOR PRE NOTICE.
AND ALSO -- ALLOW FOR RETENTION
AND SO WE'VE BEEN -- PLEASED TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR ON BOTH OF THOSE.
ARE FUNDAMENTAL CONCERN WAS THAT
IF THE IF THE DEPARTMENT'S HELD
TO A NINETY DAY APPROVAL PROCESS
THEY WON'T BEAT IT WE HOPE THAT
THEY DO -- BUT HISTORICALLY THEY
HAVE NOT AND SO WE DO APPRECIATE
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENT THAT
THAT'S BEEN TAKEN -- THAT ALLOWS
FOR THE APPLICATION PROCESS THE
CURRENT APPLICATION PROCESS TO
GO THROUGH -- IF THE DEPARTMENT
DOESN'T MEET THEIR NINETY DAY
APPROVAL -- TIME FRAME A WE
WOULD VERY MUCH APPRECIATE --
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE THE
AUTHOR AND THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE AS WELL THAT I KNOW
THAT SENATOR STONE AND THE CHAIR
ARE PART OF TO LOOKAT THIS
PROCESS AND HELP US FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO FIX IT BECAUSE IT CAN'T
GO FORWARD.
THE WAY IT CURRENTLY IS SO AGAIN
PRE SHAPED -- ALL THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING WORKING ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU.
THESE THREE TESTAMENT AND I'M
SURE THE BUDGET CHAIR HERE'S A
LOUD AND CLEAR AS WELL.
AND THAT IS ARE THE QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHOR.
I'M NOT HONORED A MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL.
SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL MOVES THE
BILL ANY FINAL COMMENTS -- THIS
IS TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS -- SOMETHING
WRONG.
THANK YOU -- MEDICARE.
THIS IS A BILL ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
CLEARLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
WORKERS WHO DEDICATE THEIR LIVES
TO ENSURING THAT THE MOST
VULNERABLE ARE PROTECTED.
AS WELL AS INSURING THAT THE
RESIDENTS OF THESE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES I HAVE THE CONTINUITY
OF CARE -- I'M REALLY THANKFUL
FOR THE SPONSORS AS WELL AS TO
THE OPPOSITION FOR IDENTIFYING
THAT WE HAVE A RESOURCE PROBLEM.
AND AS WE CONTINUE TO GROW AS A
STATE WITH A DOUBLE SENIOR
MAJORITY BOTH.
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS NOW
BEING SENIOR CITIZENS ACROSS THE
STATE WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT THIS
PROBLEM AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I FELT WE SHOULD TRY
TO FIND A PROBLEM COMING UP WITH
A SOLUTION.
I WILL GO AND CALL THE ROLL.
HANDS DOWN STONE I'D CONSOLIDATE
CONTROL AS I DROVE HER TADO
LABOR MITCHELL.
MITCHELLI MINING RUBIO THE
THREE OF US REALLY THE REAL OPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
THE WITNESSES ABOUT -- THE MONEY
[inaudible]
WHAT
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO BE A
FILE ITEM NINETEEN WE WELCOME
ASSEMBLYWOMAN FLOWN AB?
TWELVE FORTY SIX YOU KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN HUSTLIN.
WELCOME FOR HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
HERE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVE A CERTAIN MEMBERS.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AB
TWELVE FORTY SIX CLOSES A GAP IN
STATE LAW BY ENSURING CONSUMERS
WITH LARGE EMPLOYER COVERAGE
REGULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ENJOY THE SAME HEALTH
BENEFITS AND CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS ALREADY HAVE.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFITS REVIEW PROGRAM
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL THERE ARE
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA'S INSURED BY LARGE
EMPLOYER COVERAGE WHO MAY NOT
HAVE THE SAME CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND BENEFITS AS
OTHER CALIFORNIANS WHOSE
COVERAGE IS REGULATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED.
HEALTHCARE SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL REQUIRES LARGE GROUP HEALTH
INSURANCE POLICY IS REGULATED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE TO
INCLUDE THE COVERAGE FOR
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BASIC
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND
PROHIBITS ANNUAL OR LIFETIME
DOLLAR LIMITS ON BASIC
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND
MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE CONSUMERS
WITH COVERAGE REGULATED UNDER
THE KNOX KEEN ACT HAVE BEEN
GUARANTEED COVERAGE THAT
PROVIDES MEDICALLY NECESSARY
CARE INCLUDING BASIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SUCH AS DOCTOR SERVICES.
HOSPITAL SERVICES EMERGENCY CARE
LAB IMOGENE AND HOSPICE CARE
THIS BILL CODIFIES THESE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS INTO THE
INSURANCE CODE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN EYE BUT WHEN THE TIME
THANK YOU LISTEN HERE WITNESSES
ON GOOD AFTERNOON AND JDS HERE
FROM HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA PROUD
TO SPONSOR A BEETLE FORTY SIX
WHICH WOULD ESSENTIALLY LEVEL UP
THE PLAYING FIELD TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS.
WITH STATE REGULATED COVERAGE --
BENEFIT FROM THE SAME COMPLAINT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
BENEFITS REGARDLESS OF WHICH
DEPARTMENT REGULATES THEIR
COVERAGE.
A B. TWELVE FORTY SIX WOULD
PROTECT CONSUMERS WITH LARGE
GROUP COVERAGE UNDER THE
INSURANCE CODE BY CODIFYING
KNOCKS KEEN ACT BASIC HEALTHCARE
SERVICES DEFINITIONS AND
MEDICALLY NECESSARY PRESCRIPTION
DRUG PROTECTIONS INTO THE
INSURANCE CODE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CODIFY THESE
MINIMUM BENEFITS STANDARDS IN
THE INSURANCE CODE BECAUSE UNDER
FEDERAL LAW AND FEDERAL BLUE
RULES WHICH CAN CHANGE LARGE
EMPLOYER COVERAGE ONLY HAS TO
MEET.
MINIMUM VALUE THRESHOLDS MINIMUM
VALUE COVERAGE A MINIMUM VALUE
COVERAGE CAN CHANGE AND CAN
INCLUDE MANY LIMITATIONS FOR
EXAMPLE FOR EXAMPLE A HOSPITAL
STAY CAN BE COVERED.
BUT COVERAGE IS ONLY LIMITED TO
THREE TO FIVE DAYS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS THAT COVERAGE CAN
COVER DOCTOR VISITS BUT NOT
HOSPITAL VISITS.
THESE SCENARIOS CREATE GAPS IN
BENEFITS AND PROTECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH LARGE EMPLOYER
COVERAGE UNDER THE INSURANCE
CODE VERSUS THOSE UNDER THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE -- WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE IN HELPING US WITH
AMENDMENTS THAT STRIKE A BALANCE
TO ENSURE OUR TO STATE-REGULATORS RETAINED EARTH
ALREADY OVER THEIR AREAS WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TOGETHER. FOR
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT A B.
TWELVE FORTY SIX AND ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TEXT BIGGER JANICE
ROCKER DEPUTY COMMISSIONER AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AS THE AUTHOR ON THE SPONSOR
MENTIONED -- AB TWELVE FORTY SIX
REQUIRES A LARGE GROUP HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE.
COVER ALL MEDICALLY NECESSARY
BASIC HEALTHCARE SERVICES --
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BRING
DRAMATIC CHANGE TO THE LARGE
GROUP POLICIES BECAUSE MOST OF
THEM ALREADY PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE COVERAGE -- AND IT
WILL BE THAN PUTTING IT IN LINE
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL IN THE SMALL
GROUP PRODUCTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE ALREADY.
REGULATES THAT HAVE TO COVER ALL
BASIC HEALTH CARE SERVICES SO WE
SUPPORT THE BILL AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MANY
WOMEN IS IN YOUR SECTOR
ACCEPTING THE IDENTITY.
THANKS SO MUCH OUR NEXT SPEAKER.
ELLIE BEAM ABOUT HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
JAN FLOOR ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
SUPPORT.
MERCY CONSULTS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND SUPPORT.
RAIN SPENCER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
SPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU -- WHICH THEY'RE
SOLD OUT WHAT THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE MAKE ROOM FOR THEM AT THE
TABLE PLEASE [inaudible]
FROM WHICH SEVENTY LIKE IN THE
MAY HAVE THIS VISION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES WE CURRENTLY
HAVE AN OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS
BILL BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR THE SPONSOR.
AND THE DEPARTMENT FOR WORKING
WITH US WE JUST LIKE TO
BENCHMARK THE TIME FRAME ISSUES
AND WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF
TIME FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROMULGATE RAGS AND REVIEW.
THE POLICIES GOING FORWARD SO
THERE'S NOT AND DO HARM TO ANY
PLANS TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD SO
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK -- AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPEN DIALOGUE SO
FAR AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL
BE ABLE TO REMEMBER OPPOSITION.
OKAY OTHER WITNESSES ENOUGH
OPPOSITION.
JOHN LINGER ON THE F. AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS TO JUST
ECHO THE COMMENTS A CAP
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SOME KIND OF RALLY WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CAESAR AND MOTION YET.
OKAY TO MOVE BY SIR MITCHELL.
SO.
SO SEVERAL MOMENT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
AND ADDRESSES.
SUPPORT ISSUES IN TERMS OF BASIC
HEALTHCARE SERVICES THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I HAVE A VERY THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER MITCHELL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED -- SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HAND BY A STONE.
STONE NO GUNS ALL IS CONSOLE AS
I GROW HER TADO LLEVA MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I MORNING MORNING I
RUBIO.
OKAY CURRENTLY THE VOTERS FOR
ONE WILL ROUTE LEAVE THE ROAD
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU HE'S MUCH.
OKAY SO WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR
SOME MEMBER BURKE AND SENATOR
JOHN SAWYER. TO MORE ITEMS
.
OKAY LET'S CLOSE
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE AND
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO BY SOME A RIVER --
WHEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS?
GROVE HER TADO LLEVA MINING
MINING I RUBIO.
RUBIO I THAT VOTES CURRENTLY SIX
ZERO LEAVE THE ROLE OF CONTRAST
MEMBERS [inaudible]
AMOUNTS OKAY -- NEXT TIME WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE ROLE IS ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN EIGHTY TWELVE
FORTY SIX BY SOME MEMBER OF
LOANS SECURITIES CALL THE ROLE
THAT SOME MEMBERS.
ROVE HER TADO LLEVA RUBIO.
REVIEW BY.
FIVE THAT IT'S CURRENTLY FIVE
ONE LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THAT'S NOW GO PUT THE ROLAND
ITEM TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR BY SEMIREGULAR CURRY
SO YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THAT
SOME MEMBERS GROVE HER TADO
LABOR MORNING.
MORNING I RUBIO REVIEW HI SIX
ZERO THAT VOTE IS CURRENTLY.
SIX ZERO WELL THE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY WE HAVE -- NEXT ITEMS I AND
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE BY SOME
MEMBER CORREO -- THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS SIX
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS FAN HI.
I GROVE HER TADO LAVER MORNING
MORNING I RUBIO.
REVIEW BY. SIX OF THAT VOTE THAT
CURRENTLY IS A SIX ZERO OR HOLD
THE ROLE.
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THE NOVEMBER OPEN THE ROLE AND
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY NINE BY
SEPARATE DAILY SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
GROVE HER TADO LLEVA.
MORNING.
MORNING I RUBIO.
REVEALED BY.
THE BILLS CURRENTLY SIX ZERO ALL
THE ROLL UP IN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WHAT WE GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SO WE HAVE?
I OKAY HE DID ALL RIGHT WELL YOU
KNOW WHAT.
OKAY SO WE HAVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SIX THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AN HI I DROVE
HER TADO LLEVA.
MORNING MORNING I REVIEW.
REVIEW BY.
THE CONSENT CALENDARS FIVE ZERO
AND I'M GLAD TO KNOW THAT
SENATOR MITCHELL'S EYES ARE
STILL INTACT
.
SO AGAIN -- FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING -- AND I KNOW PEOPLE
ARE BUSY IN THERE AND VERY
SQUEEZING A PRESENTING -- WE ARE
WAITING FOR TWO MORE AUTHORS.
AS A MEMBER BURKE IN THE SUMMER
JONES SAWYER
SO I UNDERSTAND
THAT -- THERE IS A STAFF PERSON
WHO'S GOT A PRESENTS ON BEHALF
OF A SUMMER BURKE WHICH WE SO
WELL COME.
RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND TAKE UP.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY TWO AND WELCOME.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND CERTAINLY THE BILLS
AND MOVE BEFORE YOU'VE PRESENTED.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELCOME NUMBER BRICK
HELLO.
MY NAME IS RENEE IS TO IS TO
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE - WE'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE
ON THE BILL.
AS DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS AS
SHE IS OFFERING AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WHICH DELAY
THE EFFECTIVE DATE UTIL JULY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PERMIT A
HOSPITAL THAT PREACHERS AT THE
SYSTEM LEVEL TO REPORT ON THE
SYSTEM WIDE LEVEL.
AND CHANGING VETERAN OWNED
BUSINESSES TO DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS TO CONFORM TO EXISTING
DIVERSITY REPORTING PROGRAMS.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE BEING
DISTRIBUTED TO EACH OF YOU NOW
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE A COPY OF
THEM.
EXCELLENT AT CENTERS EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY TWO WOULD REQUIRE
HOSPITALS WITH OVER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN OPERATING
EXPENSES TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO
THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT.
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE THE HOSPITAL
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY AND EFFORTS
TO INCREASE THAT DIVERSITY.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT ESTABLISH
QUOTAS IT ONLY ENCOURAGES
HOSPITALS TO TAKE A DEEPER LOOK
INTO OUR SUPPLIER DIVERSITY
PROCUREMENT EFFORTS.
ARE SEEN AS ONE THAT TAKES PRIDE
IN ITS DIVERSITY AND FOR THAT
REASON WE MUST CONTINUE TO
PROMOTE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED.
DIVERSE BUSINESSES PROVIDE
NUMEROUS BENEFITS TO LOCAL
COMMON ECONOMIES ACCORDING TO
THE U. S. SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION 42% OF ALL
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE OR
MINORITY OWNED.
FURTHER MORE DIVERSE BUSINESSES
ARE MORE LIKELY TO OPERATE A
SMALL BUSINESSES AND HIRE PEOPLE
FROM DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS
PROVIDING A PATHWAY TO FINANCIAL
SECURITY.
ABOARD WERE BOTH MOBILITY FIRST
DIRECTLY UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES BY REQUIRING
HOSPITALS TO BE TRANSPARENT
THEIR PROCUREMENT EFFORTS AND
PRACTICES A. B. NINE SIX TO
ENSURE THAT OUR WOMEN AND
MINORITY LGBT.
A DISABLED VETERAN OWNED
BUSINESSES HAVE ACCESS TO MORE
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES WITH ME
IN SUPPORT IS ANDREW LACY.
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH EQUITY THE
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK CAN I VOTE.
THANK YOU WELCOME HE'S BEEN GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS I THINK A LOT SAYING I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH EQUITY AT THE
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE.
A STATEWIDE MULTI ETHNIC POLICY
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO RACIAL
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE WE'RE PROUD
TO SUPPORT A B. NINE SIXTY TWO
BECAUSE THIS BILL WILL PROMOTE
DIVERSITY EQUITY INCLUSION.
BY REQUIRING HOSPITALS TO
ANNUALLY DISCLOSE OUR SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY GOALS AND PROCUREMENT.
WITH BUSINESSES OWNED BY PEOPLE
OF COLOR WOMEN L. G. D. L. G. B.
T. PEOPLE AND DISABLED VETERANS.
OUR STATE CURRENTLY LACKS DATA
ABOUT HOW HOSPITALS CONDUCT
THEIR PROCUREMENT.
AB NINETY TWO WILL ALLOW
HEALTHCARE BUSINESS AND
GOVERNMENT LEADERS TO LEVERAGE
THE GROWTH OF THE HEALTH SECTOR
TO BENEFIT DIVERSE BUSINESSES
AND COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
BUT SEVERAL EXAMPLES ACROSS THE
STATE THAT INDICATE THAT
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY REPORTING
WILL INCREASE OPPORTUNITIES IN
CAPITAL FOR DIVERSE BUSINESSES.
SAMPLE WHEN THE CPUC BEGAN
TRACKING SUPPLIER DIVERSITY IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX DIVERSE
BUSINESS IS ONLY RECEIVED TWO
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
CONTRACTS HOWEVER BY.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN UTILITIES
PROCURED OVER TEN BILLION
DOLLARS FROM DIVERSE SUPPLIERS
ADDITIONALLY AFTER THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE BEGAN
TRACKING SUPPLIER DIVERSITY IN.
TWENTY TWELVE CONTRACTING A
BETWEEN LARGE INSURERS AND
DIVERSE BUSINESSES INCREASED.
FROM NINE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
IN TWENTY TWELVE TO ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION.
IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE EXPECT
THAT'S A PART OF OUR CITY
REPORTING FOR HOSPITALS WILL
YIELD SIMILAR RESULTS WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO FIND COMMON GROUND.
THANK YOU AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I BUILT.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
XENON WITNESSES OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME TO THE TABLE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
CATHERINE LOSSES GOT CAUGHT
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION --
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THIS JUST TO BE CLEAR
THAT -- OUR HOSPITALS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OPERATIONALLY AUTHORIZATION.
OPERATIONALIZE SING -- THIS
PROCESS WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF
SUPPLIERS MANY OF THE SUPPLIERS
ARE MULTINATIONAL COMPANIES AS
WE WORK TO KEEP.
COSTS DOWN.
GROUP PURCHASING ORGANIZATIONS --
WHERE WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
IMPACT THE DIVERSITY OF A
MULTINATIONAL COMPANY IF YOU'RE
A SMALL MEDIUM OR OR MEDIUM SIZE
HOSPITAL SO WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH HOW?
WE CAN MANAGE -- THE EXPECTATION
THAT WILL BE SET AS WE REPORT TO
IMPROVE DIVERSITY WITH THE
REALITY OF WHO WE SUPPLY WHERE --
WE PURCHASED OUR SUPPLIES FROM
LIKE MULTINATIONAL GPO TO KEEP
OUR COSTS DOWN OR KEEP
EFFICIENCIES -- AND AND HOW
THAT'S GOING TO COME OUT IN THE
REPORTING PROCESS -- GREEN
LIGHTING HAS PROVIDED THE AUTHOR
PROVIDED SOME AMENDMENTS BUT
WE'RE STILL CONCERNED -- THAT
WHAT WE MAY END UP WITH IS A A
FRUSTRATING REPORTING PROCESSES
WE MANAGED LARGE I'M GROUP
PURCHASING IDEAS AND TRY -- TO I
KNOW THAT THE GOAL IS TO FOCUS
ON THE LOCAL PURCHASE SO I'M
TRYING TO BALANCE THOSE NEEDS
WITH OUR HOSPITALS AS WELL AS
KEEP THE COSTS DOWN ON ALL OF
THIS IS REALLY -- WHY WERE BYRON
OPPOSING THE BILL -- AND TRYING
TO WORK THROUGH THOSE CONCERNS.
OKAY THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
NOT POSITION.
MONEY DELGADO THE DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUM WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION I BELIEVE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS OKAY THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT SO THE BILLS RVEN MOVE
THEIR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS SAYS CENTER LOOPY RUBIO
YEAH I JUST WANNA ADDRESS
BECAUSE IT IT HERE'S WHAT I'M
SORRY I'M TRYING TO FIND YOU
HAVE BEEN STILL IN COMMUNICATION
AND TRYING TO COME TO THAT
MIDDLE GROUND AND YOU'RE STILL
WORKING AT IT.
IS THAT WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING
CORRECT WE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW -- TO FOR THE LARGER
PURCHASES AT A SYSTEM WIDE LEVEL
FOR EXAMPLE VERSES THE LOCAL
PURCHASES -- AND HOW TO DO THAT
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T
IMMEDIATELY PENALIZED HOSPITALS
IF THEY DON'T HAVE A CHOICE --
IN THAT REPORTING PROCESS SO WE
ARE WE ARE TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH THAT LANDED YET BUT WE
ARE TRYING TO WORK THROUGH THAT.
AND SO MANY BURKE IS STILL
WORKING UP INTO THAT'S CORRECT
HERSELF DOING EXCELLENT JOB I
THINK YEAH.
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY.
US AIR TIME [inaudible]
SO.
THE ANNOUNCER HERE.
PROVIDES ITS WITH INFORMATION
THERE'S ABOUT. FORTY FOUR FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE HOSPITALS
LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA WHICH YOU
BELIEVE THIS WEIGHT.
IMPACT ALL YEAH. FOR OF THE
THRESHOLD IS FOR TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR HOSPITALS WITH
OPERATING EXPENSES OVER TWENTY
FIVE MILLION -- THAT THRESHOLD
AT IT -- TRACKS DIRECTLY TO WHAT
THE C. P. U. C. LEVERAGES FOR
UTILITIES THAT AMOUNTS TO ABOUT
75% OF HOSPITALS ACROSS THE
STATE.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY OF THOSE ARE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY -- NOT OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD -- CENTER BUT
WE CAN DEFINITELY FIND THAT
INFORMATION GET IT TO YOU.
FROM EXPERIENCE YOU'RE GONNA
CATCH SOME OF YOUR HOSPITALS OF
THE MEDIUM SIZE HOSPITALS BUT
THERE WILL BE A COUPLE THAT
WON'T BE CAUGHT UNDER THE BILL
WITH THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
EXPENDITURES -- A COUPLE JUST
JUST A AT THIS BECAUSE I KNOW
THEM FUNDING QUESTION.
WE CAN PROBABLY GET YOU THAT.
LISTIA.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OKAY SEE NONE -- I THINK THIS
FAMILY MEMBER AND THANK YOU --
FOR ACTUALLY -- ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS -- I KNOW WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON TRYING SO WE HAVE THE
MINUTES TRYING TO DRESS TO
SYSTEMS I REALIZE THAT THERE MAY
pBUT WE DID TRY ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE.
SO SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP AND I ASSUME
THAT ZERO HERE SITTING IN FOR
THE SUMMER -- WOMAN THAT SHE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO HOPEFULLY.
THAT THE JUST ADDRESS ANY FINAL
CONCERNS CERTAINLY -- COMMITTED
TO WORKING TOGETHER TO CREATE A
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTION -- IF THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL AND IT IS IS
TO PROMOTE DIVERSITY AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY WE THINK
REPORTING AND DATA CAN HELP
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL SO WE ASKED
FOR AND I VOTE.
OKAY WELL CERTAINLY THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT -- THING TO
ACHIEVE SO I CERTAINLY URGE THE
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION REALIZED OR
SOME COMPLICATIONS AND
OPERATIONALIZE IN BUT WE DO NEED
TO ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF THE BILL.
AND SISTERLY I'M GONNA BE IN THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
APPRECIATE AGAIN TAKING THE
MEDICINE TRIED DRESSES
OPERATIONAL ISSUES AND LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE WORK ON THAT.
SIR DID YOU WANT TO CLOSE ANY
FURTHER I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SIR
MITCHELL THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AN HI CAN I STONE.
STONE NOW GONZALEZ CONSOLES I
GROVE HER TADO FURTADO I LABOR
LABOR I MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I MORNING MORNING I
REVIEW.
REVIEW BY [inaudible] SEVEN ONE
OKAY THE VOTE SEVEN ONE THE BILL
IS OUT THE FIRST BALL OUT.
HIS HEARING OKAY HANK YOU.
RIGHT SO WE'RE JUST FINALLY
WAITING FOR ONE MORE MEMBERS --
SUMMER JOAN SAWYER BUT WHILE
WE'RE WAITING LET'S GO AHEAD AND
GO THROUGH THE REST OF THE BILLS.
START WITH CONSENT THIRTY ONE OF
THEM WITH A NUMBER ONE WHICH IS
SO WE'RE GONNA GO DOWN FILE
ORDER -- IS THAT WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR THAT ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN TO BE PRESENTED --
BUT WHAT WE'RE DOING AND SO
LET'S START WITH ITEM NUMBER.
ONE SP SIX SIX FIVE BY CENTER --
BURKE -- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS -- SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS GROWTH LLEVA LABOR I
EIGHT ZERO OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY TWO OH FOUR BY
SOME A MEMBER WOULD ADD MOTIONS
TO PASS REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT IT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
LABOR LABOR I EIGHT ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FOUR ONE FOUR
BY SOME MEMBER FONT -- THE
MOTIONS TO PASSES AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATION SECTOR THESE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS THROW
FLAVA.
FLAV AS I SEVEN ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT SEVEN ONE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE BY
SEVEN MEMBER TEAM THE MOTIONS TO
PASS REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROWTH LABOR LABOR I SEVEN ONE
THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN ONE AND I
SEE SOME MEMBER JOHN SAWYER SO
WE WILL PAUSE THE ROLE HERE.
AND ALLOW HIM TO PRESENT WELCOME
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN OH NINE WELCOME
[inaudible]
I WILL [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON. TO START BY
TAKING THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY WHICH
CLARIFY THAT NURSING
ADMINISTRATORS WITH.
WITH OUT WITH OUT OF STATE
LICENSES ARE STILL SUBJECT TO
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS ONCE THEY EARNED A
CALIFORNIA LICENSE.
AB SEVENTEEN OH NINE PROVIDES
SKILLED URSING FACILITIES
ABILITY DEDICATE RESOURCES TO
TRAIN.
THEIR SKILLED WORKFORCE
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
NURSING HOME ADMINISTRATORS TO
RENEW THEIR LICENSES AND SURE
STAY.
OVERSIGHT OF LICENSURE EXAMS
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES ONE
PRECEPTOR PER SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES SINCE THE PRECEPTORS
OFTEN ADMINISTRATOR AS SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY THIS CAN
UNNECESSARILY LIMITING FOR
LICENSED FACILITIES FOR MORE
THAN ONE LOCATION AB SEVENTEEN
OH NINE ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
ALLOWING SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY TO HAVE A DEDICATED
PRECEPTOR.
THAT COULD SERVICE TO DESIGNATED
TRAINER AND MULTIPLE FACILITIES.
THIS LIST NURSING HOME
ADMINISTRATOR FOCUS ON MANAGING
THE FACILITY TO ENSURE ALL
PATIENTS ARE RECEIVING THE CARE
DAY SEE.
WITH ME TODAY IS A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR LEADING EDGE
CALIFORNIA SPONSORS OF THE BILL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU SHERRIN MEMBERS SHED
HAMPTON REPRESENT LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA OUR ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTS OVER SIX HUNDRED NOT
FOR PROFIT PROVIDERS A SENIOR
FOR HOUSING KAREN SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE CHAIR FOR
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
AS WELL AS THE AUTHOR AND HE
GAVE ME QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN THE BILLS THE NEW
BY CENTER STONE OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
IN A PERCENT OR MAY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT -- ANYWAY
THIS IS AN OPPOSITION.
SAY NONE -- QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
SAME.
A CENTER MITCHELL. FOR GETTING
MOVED TO BAIL.
RIGHT SEEN NONE.
HAS OR EVEN MOVE BY SENATOR
STONE I WHAT THANK YOU AS OR DOW
JONES FOR WORKING WITH -- HIRES
COMMITTEE STAFF AND ON THAT
ACCEPTING THE MINUTES WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE SPECS -- ASTRI I VOTE
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO THE
EMOTIONS DO PASSES AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND BY.
STONE STONE I CONSOLIDATES
GONZALES SIDE GROWTH HER TACO.
TACO I LLEVA LEAVE I MITCHELL
MITCHELL I MORNING MORNING I
RUBIO.
REVIEW BY EIGHT ZERO AT BILLS
OUT EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU.
SEE YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
RESUME OUR ROLE HERE.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE JUST COMPLETED
SO THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT THAT'S EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SEVEN MEMBER EDMUND
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROWTH LABOR LABOR HI. EIGHT
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER NINE
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY ONE BY SUMMER
GRAYSON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATION SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT SOME MEMBERS GROW
FLAVA.
FLAV I EIGHT ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT -- EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEM IS.
NOTED THE THIRTEEN SO NEXT ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
ACTUALLY ELEMENT WE DID THIS.
I AM NUMBER SEVENTEEN A B..
ELEVEN LIVE IN.
THAT AREA YEAH I NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
BY SOME MEMBER -- WHEN THAT
SPECIAL SKI PASSES AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATION SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE
HER TADO?
HER TITLE I IT LABOR LABOR I
EIGHT ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN EIGHTY TWELVE
FORTY SIX BY SOME MEMBER LIMO
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
SEPARATE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE HER TACO.
HER TITLE I LABOR LABOR I SEVEN
ONE THAT BILL WAS OUT SEVEN ONE
THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHTY TWELVE FORTY NINE
BY SOME MEMBER MAN SHY THE
MOTIONS TO PASSES AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WITH THESE
CALL THE ROLE THAT THE NUMBERS.
GROW.
LABOR LABOR HI -- EIGHT THAT
BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR BY SUMMER
AGARIC HURRIED EMOTIONS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS ACT IF
THESE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS GROVE HER TATO.
HER TITLE I'D LLEVA FLAVOR I EAT.
THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO SIX
ITEMS I'M NUMBER TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY BY
SEPTEMBER PONTA EMOTIONS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS EQUITIES CULTURAL
ABSENT MEMBERS ROSE LLEVA.
LABOR I THAT'S EIGHT THAT BILL
IS OUT EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
SIXTEEN FORTY TWO BY SOME MEMBER
WOULD MOTIONS TO PASSES AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATION SECTOR THIS CALL
THE ROAD AFTER MEMBERS.
GROVE FLAVA FLAV IT I SEVEN ONE
THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN ONE NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE BY
SEVEN REMEMBER.
CORREO -- THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
A MENTOR FOR TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATION SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE
HER TATO HER TITLE I LLEVA.
LABOR I EIGHT ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE BY SEPTEMBER
PONTA EMOTIONS TO PASS REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SEPARATE THESE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS ROW
LLEVA.
LABOR I EIGHT ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT EIGHT ZERO THEN WE HAVE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY NINE BY SAM REMEMBERED
DELETE.
AND EMOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SEPARATELY SO I
WAS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE HER TAUT
AND HER TITLE I LABOR.
LABOR I EIGHT ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT EIGHT ZERO AND FINALLY WE
HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THAT WE HAVE SEVERAL ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH I
THINK YOU KNOW WHAT THEY ARE --
SO WHO WAS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR GROVE HER
TADO. FOR TITLE II LABOR LABOR I
THE CONSENT CALENDARS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO THIS CONCLUDES THE
AGENDA OF THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
THOUGH I WISH EVERYONE A
WONDERFUL SUMMER RECESS WE'LL BE
BACK NOT DOES THIS COMMITTEE
WILL BE BACK AT WORK I'M SURE ON
THE FLOOR -- BUT WE HAVE
ESSENTIALLY CONCLUDED OUR AGENDA
AND THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU